bonjour à tous hier en début de soirée
les sénateurs ont adopté le projet de
loi de programmation militaire pour la
période s'écoulant de 2014 à 2019
ce texte fixe le cadre budgétaire et le
cadre législatif de la défense pour les
chips six prochaines années il prévoit
notamment le maintien du budget à 31,4
milliards d'euros par an jusqu'en 2016
il prévoit également la suppression de
34 mille postes d'ici six ans cette
réduction des effectifs a été largement
critiquée hier par l'ump mais ce qui a
suscité le plus de débats hier et bien
c'est l'article 13 de ce projet de loi
débat suscité notamment chez de nombreux
acteurs du numérique puisque cet article
13 prévoit l'accès renforçait des
services de renseignement de la
gendarmerie et de la police aux données
téléphoniques et aux données
informatiques
cela dans le cadre de la lutte contre le
terrorisme et contre la criminalité
organisée tout de suite donc retour à
cette séance qui s'est déroulée hier
soir au sénat la parole est un autre
collègue michèle demessine pour le
groupe crc mes chers collègues nous
avons douze intervenants dans la
discussion générale c'est très bien je
vais demander à nos collègues de rester
dans les temps
bon le temps qu'il aura été un parti
vraiment je serai à cheval sur le temps
et vous allez bon excusé par avance ce
n'est pas mon habitude mais là il faudra
respecter le temps merci madame de
messine
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues l'examen en
seconde lecture de la loi de
programmation militaire
2014-2019 prend bien sûr un relief tout
particulier avec le sommet franco
africain pour la paix la sécurité en
afrique lieu cette phase semaine et la
résolution de l'onu sur notre
intervention militaire en centrafrique
ces deux événements illustrent
concrètement notre discussion de cet
après midi puisque nous examinons les
moyens les grandes orientations et les
enjeux que ce qui sont ceux de notre
défense pour les six années à venir lors
de l'examen en première lecture notre
groupe vous avez clairement dit monsieur
le ministre
notre opposition à certaines de vos
conceptions stratégiques
elles ne correspondent pas à nos yeux à
notre conception d'une défense national
progressiste qui permettent à la fois de
défendre les intérêts de notre pays et
de son peuple de promouvoir nos valeurs
mais aussi de mettre en oeuvre une
politique étrangère d'influents ce qui
favorise l'émergence d'un monde plus
juste et plus solidaire et qui fasse
progresser la paix et le désarmement
nous avions également relevé qu'il n'y
avait pas de dire qu'il n'y avait pas de
différence assez nettement affirmée avec
la politique menée par le précédent
président de la république voire même
qu'il y avait une certaine continuité
nous avions ainsi pris les exemples de
la pleine réintégration dans le
commandement militaire de l'otan ou de
l'ouverture d'une nouvelle base à abou
dhabi comme étant ceux de réorientation
stratégique majeure qui traduisait un
alignement sur des positions atlantistes
sans débat national approfondi autre que
parlementaire sans même parler de notre
désaccord fondamental avec la conception
de la dissuasion nucléaire qui est celle
du président de la république et de la
part budgétaire trop importante qui lui
est accordée au détriment de nos forces
conventionnelles
ainsi le texte de la lpm qui nous
revient après son examen par l'assemblée
nationale n'est pas de nature à nous
faire changer l'appréciation sur ces
aspects de notre politique de défense
ceci étant dit un raisonnement
mécaniques voire simpliste aurait pu
nous amener à penser que la lpm étant
comme son nom l'évoqué en partie la
traduction financière et budgétaire des
grandes orientations de la politique de
défense proposées par le gouvernement
nous devrions la rejeter en bloc parce
que nous en parce que nous en rejetons
certains aspects notre démarche est la
réalité des choses sont plus complexes
nous sommes fermement attachés à un
certain nombre de principes en
particulier au fait que nos forces
armées sont celles de notre république
nous estimons que notre qu'ils défense
doit pouvoir disposer d'eux des moyens
garantissant son efficacité et sa
crédibilité pour assurer les missions
qui lui sont confiées au nom de notre
pays
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
reconnu monsieur le ministre que dans un
budget contraint en préservant un
plancher minimum de ressources vous
aviez tenu le pari de résoudre une
difficile équation celle de réussir à
maintenir malgré tout notre niveau
stratégique et notre statut
international en maintenant la
crédibilité de la dissuasion nucléaire
même si nous ne partageons pas votre
conception en continuant d'assurer la
protection du territoire et en réduisant
quelque peu nos capacités d'intervention
hors du territoire national
tout cela afin de garantir notre
autonomie stratégique et financière qui
sont des éléments fondamentaux de la
souveraineté nationale pour ce qui est
de l'aspect budgétaire nos collègues à
l'assemblée nationale n'ont pas
réellement modifier l'équilibré général
de la loi ils ont maintenu et c'était
très important
l'intégralité des garanties qu'ils
avaient qui avait été introduite ici en
particulier les clauses de sauvegarde
celle de revoyure est de retour à
meilleure fortune ou bien encore les
dispositifs relatifs au contrôle
parlementaire de l'exécution toute chose
ayant été l'objet d'une très forte
mobilisation de notre commission et de
son président je note avec satisfaction
la majoration de 500 millions d'euros
des roses des ressources exceptionnelles
afin de garantir le financement des
premiers programmes d'équipement à skier
dans la loi de la même façon à la suite
de l'amputation de 650 millions d'euros
de crédits d'équipement dans le projet
de budget rectificatif 2013 vous avez
pris l'engagement en le faisant inscrire
dans la loi que toutes les opérations
d'investissement prévues soient réalisés
dont acte enfin pour ce qui concerne le
surcoût des opérations extérieures qui
comme on l'a vu avec cette nouvelle
intervention en centrafrique pèse
lourdement sur nos finances publiques au
détriment d'autres priorités vous avez
heureusement obtenu qu'il soit financé
par la solidarité interministérielle à
hauteur de 578 millions d'euros je note
aussi votre volonté de demander lors du
prochain conseil européen de défense
l'extension du mécanisme européen athena
qui permet le financement en commun
d'une partie des dépenses relatives à
des opérations militaires menées dans le
cadre de l'union européenne il faut
toutefois prendre cette louable
attention pour ce qu'elle est car
actuellement l'union européenne est très
loin d'avoir une politique commune de
défense enfin le système d'indemnisation
des victimes des victimes des essais
nucléaires a aussi progressé
positivement et vous y avait ajouté
quelques dispositions mais il en faudra
nous le savons d'autres pour que ce
dispositif reconnaisse pleinement un
droit à l'indemnisation de ces victimes
qui aujourd'hui reste trop peu nombreux
à être reconnu en tant que tel mais ceci
est une première avancée et nous allons
continuer à y travailler
néanmoins malgré tous les garde-fous
budgétaire j'ai encore comme en première
lecture des doutes sur la cohérence
capacitaires et l'acompte
compatibilité entre les moyens alloués
dans votre loi et les ambitions
stratégiques élevés qui sont affichés
dans le livre blanc comment tout cela
pourra-t-il réellement fonctionner avec
un budget dont la stabilité repose en
grande partie sur des choix dont je les
dis je ne partage pas bien fondé en
particulier celui de la poursuite d'une
diminution drastique des effectifs
ces suppressions d'emplois qui ne
devraient principalement toucher
que le soutien et l'administrative ne
peuvent être sans conséquences néfastes
sont la cohérence et les capacités de
notre outil de défense conventionnelle
qui risque nous craignons d'être
affaibli
les disparités d'unités de base ou
d'établissement a malheureusement aussi
toujours de graves répercussions sur la
situation de nos territoires et de leurs
populations
en fin de compte et sont toujours
fortement la possibilité de cessions de
participations de l'état dans nos
industries vous connaissez notre
position sur ce sujet pour compenser un
manque de ressources c'est une politique
de gribouille qui constitue à nos yeux
de nouveaux abandons dans la maîtrise
publique dans des secteurs déterminant
pour l'indépendance et la souveraineté
nationale nous y tenons particulièrement
particulièrement à ce propos la façon
dont le groupe eads restructure ses
activités de défense en sacrifiant ses
salariés en vue de préserver la
rentabilité financière du groupe
illustre les dangers d'une telle
démarche en effet si ce groupe se permet
aujourd'hui de telles pratiques c'est
bien parce que l'état actionnaire s'est
de lui-même considérablement affaibli
dans la gouvernance de l'entreprise nous
ne pouvons plus exercer aucune influence
sur la stratégie industrielle
il ne reste plus aujourd'hui au
gouvernement qu'à rappeler monsieur
enders à ses obligations
d'accompagnement social
voilà monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues j'ai exposé les raisons pour
lesquelles le groupe communiste
républicain et citoyen contesté certains
choix effectués dans cette loi de
programmation militaire mais dans le
même temps nous sommes conscients que
cette loi et d'un équilibre fragile en
outre elle tente dans une période
complexe et pleine d'incertitudes deux
sauvegardes et une défense nationale qui
soit autant que faire se peut
stratégiquement autonome en cherchant à
sauvegarder cet outil il s'agit de
l'indépendance et de la souveraineté de
notre pays nous y sommes comme vous
comme nous profondément vous comme nous
profondément attaché enfin vous venez de
réaffirmer tout à l'heure dans votre
propos votre appui pour l'ouverture d'un
débat
sur la dissuation nucléaire tout en
réaffirmant vos convictions je le
précise et celle du gouvernement dans le
cadre de la commission de la défense de
l'assemblée nationale nous on nous l'a
t'on comme étant une ouverture pour
aller vers ce débat c'est pourquoi donc
malgré nos divergences et nos critiques
de fond sur certaines orientations
stratégiques
notre groupe maintiendra son abstention
sur la loi de programmation militaire
pour les années 2014 2015 merci de votre
attention merci madame domicile
la parole est à jean pierre chevènement
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues l'adoption
par le sénat en deuxième lecture de la
loi de programmation militaire dans le
texte issu des travaux de l'assemblée
nationale et utilement précisé à cette
occasion
marquera la fin positive d'un long
marathon que vous avez su mener à bien à
partir de l'arbitrage initiale du
président de la république assure à nos
armes est une ressource total de crédit
de 190 milliards d'euros sur six ans mon
concours et plus généralement celui des
sénateurs rdse au nom desquels je
m'exprime ne vous manquera ne vous
manqueront pas plus à l'issue de la
seconde lecture que de la première
je me suis déjà exprimé
dans le débat en première lecture je ne
reviens pas sur le contenu de la loi de
programmation militaire que j'approuve
comme l'a rappelé le président de notre
commission et étrangères et de la
défense monsieur jean louis carrère dont
je tiens à saluer le travail tout à fait
considérable et l'implication constante
l'assemblée nationale a approuvé la
plupart des avancées introduites par le
sénat notamment les clauses de
sauvegarde permettant le respect de la
trajectoire financière dessiné par la
loi de programmation militaire à
l'initiative du gouvernement une
majorette une majoration potentiel des
recettes exceptionnelles à hauteur de
500 millions d'euros a été introduite
pour compenser les annulations de
crédits de la fin de la gestion 2013 que
vous avez dû accepter en effet le
ministère de la défense a dû contribuer
à hauteur de 4 186 millions d'euros à
l'effort de réduction des déficits
publics demandé à tous les ministères
pour que l'état puisse tenir les
engagements européens qui l'a pris en la
matière c'est à ce prix que la
commission européenne a donné et son
satisfecit au budget 2014
par ailleurs votre ministère devra
pendant charge en dépassement de la
masse salariale de 232 millions d'euros
due pour les trois quarts aux
dysfonctionnements du système le vois je
ne vous demanderai pas
combien vous espérer récupérer du trop
versé
vous avez obtenu monsieur mise sur le
dégel de la plus grande partie des
crédits liés à la réserve de précaution
et couverture par des crédits
interministériel de l'intégralité du
surcoût des opex soit 1,26 milliard
dont 630 millions seulement avaient été
budgétés je mesure tout ce qu'il vous a
fallu de ténacité
pour obtenir ces résultats
il n'en reste pas moins que vous héritez
d'une bosse six jeux plus employer ce
terme qui ne vous convient pas du tout
mais de deux prêts de 3 milliards
d'euros une bosse dons
vous avez hérité qui n'est pas la vôtre
une bosse qui résulte de la gestion
précédente mais qui n'en fait pas moins
peser un lourd handicap de départ sur le
respect de la trajectoire financière de
la programmation inévitablement exposés
à de multiples aléas
le surcoût réel des opérations
extérieures dépassera est inévitablement
les 450 millions prévus par la loi de
finances 2014 avec la prolongation de
cerval qui mobilise encore au mali deux
mille hommes et lancement centrafrique
de l'opération 100 garris avec ses 100
hommes à mon tour je m'incline devant
nos deux soldats tombés
ce jour et je m'associe à la douleur de
leurs familles
au titre des charges non prévu à ce jour
il faudra quand même financer les
formations des amis de soldats africains
par an à laquelle le président de la
république s'est engagé au sommet
africain de paris le 6 décembre dernier
le président a annoncé que l'opération 5
harris serait courte et plus facile
cependant de prendre un billet aller
qu'à billet de retour nous avons tous
par expérience un au mali le deuxième
tour des élections législatives a lieu
dimanche prochain le 15 décembre le mali
est un pays indépendant comme son
président nous l'a rappelé très
récemment il lui incombe donc de
résoudre par lui-même le problème
structurel qui est le sien depuis sur
l'indépendance en 1960 et de le faire
par le dialogue autant que possible
conformément aux accords de ouagadougou
pour ce qui concerne serval il
paraîtrait raisonnable d'atteindre
rapidement l'objectif de 1000 hommes
initialement prévus pour la fin de
l'année les autorités maliennes savent
que les groupes terroristes qui
subsistent dans le nord du pays pour
être réduits doivent être coupés de la
population dont le soutien conditionne
le retour à une paix durable
la formation de troupes africaines de
maintien de l'ordre est donc un objectif
essentiel et urgent comme l'a rappelé
justement le président de la république
on y on n'imagine pas cependant que la
communauté internationale
l'onu et l'union européenne en
particulier parce que malgré tout nous
assurons aussi
sa défense puisse se décharger de cette
mission sur la france pour en revenir
aux inévitables tensions qui pèse d'ores
et déjà sur l'exécution de votre budget
2014 il est nécessaire monsieur mise que
vous obteniez de vos collègues des
finances et du budget l'inscription de
la prochaine loi de finances
rectificative des 500 millions de
ressources exceptionnelles afin de
sécuriser la programmation des
opérations d'armement jusqu'à la clause
de revoyure prévue en 2015 cette
activation rapide est d'autant plus
nécessaire que la réalisation de
recettes exceptionnelles prévues par la
loi de programmation militaire que
prendre du temps comme l'avait fait
observer la cour des comptes dans son
rapport de juillet 2012 j'ajoute que les
ressources exceptionnelles pour les
années 2014 2015 2016 atteignent 4 8
milliards d'euros soit 5 4% des crédits
consacrés à la défense des décisions
rapides peuvent être prises concernant
par exemple l'ouverture du capital
d'entreprises publiques qui ne se situe
pas forcément dans le secteur de
l'armement mais où la participation de
l'état est très fortement majoritaire
sans préjudice donc pour l'indépendance
nationale
la contradiction entre nos engagements
européens et le souci que vous avez
réitérée de haut à la france conservait
en europe une posture militaire de
premier rang implique monsieur ministre
en toute bonne logique que les dépenses
consacrées les défenses viennent en
déduction du déficit autorisé par les
traités européens
comme l'eau suggéré dans le débat
précédent monsieur rebsamen et monsieur
carrère il me semble que cette demande
va être effectuée officiellement par le
président de république par le
gouvernement prochain conseil européen
même si ça prend un peu de temps là
aussi nous savons que naturellement
l'europe n'est pas posée
seul un état comme la france ou la
grande-bretagne ont la vélocité
nécessaires pour intervenir
militairement avec efficacité nous
savons que stratégiquement l'europe a
déjà démontré son impotence 1 et par
conséquent ce sont les états qui ont la
capacité de réagir vite et quand il le
faut dans le cadre des résolutions de
l'onu
entendue et pas besoin d'y assister
j'aimerais pour conclure monsieur
ministère pour m'en tenir aux souhaits
exprimés par madame la présidente 1 et
là je suis dans mon temps de parole un
jeu fait remarquer à la haute assemblée
j'aimerais que vous nous confirmer les
propos du délégué général à l'armement
concernant les perspectives de ventes à
l'exportation des rafales j'aimerais
aussi que vous nous préciser où en est
la coopération avec les grandes la
grande bretagne et d'autres partenaires
européens s'agissant de la construction
d'une industrie européenne des drones
il serait paradoxal que le déclassement
stratégiques de la france apparaissent
comme la résultante du show européen
fait il y à plus de deux décennies est
maintenu depuis lors par les plus hautes
autorités de l'état serait peut-être
temps de revoir non pas l'objectif mais
les termes de contrats sous cette
modeste réserve qui m'est personnelle
j'approuve comme la totalité des
sénateurs du groupe rdse le projet de
loi de programmation militaire avec les
modifications introduites par
l'assemblée nationale qui ne changent
pas la structure du texte sur lequel
nous étions déjà prononcée le 21 octobre
ce contrat nous engage tous car c'est de
la survie de la france comme grande
nation politique qu'il s'agit vous vous
êtes battus monsieur le ministre pour y
arriver mais nous avons encore à nous
battre tous ensemble pour qu'il soit
jusqu'au bout intégralement tenu le
temps est venu le temps est venu merci
la parole est à corinne bouchoux du
groupe écologiste
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur
messieurs les présidents des commissions
des affaires étrangères de la défense et
des forces armées de la commission des
lois la douzième heure de programmation
militaire que nous examinons aujourd'hui
en deuxième lecture fixe un horizon de
six ans les priorités opérationnelles et
les choix majeurs en matière
d'équipement et d'effectifs et donc
aussi les dépenses militaires pour les
années 2014 à 2019 trois points ont
retenu notre attention
la défense est le troisième poste des
dépenses de l'état après l'éducation et
la dette et reçoit chaque année 31,4
milliards d'euros
le projet de loi comporte des
initiatives qu'il convient de saluer
elles permettront d'améliorer le
fonctionnement de l'armée française et
le quotidien de nos soldats que nous
saluons ici ou encore celles portant sur
les projets d'équipement où la priorité
accordée à l'entraînement et dans une
certaine mesure aux renseignements tout
comme l'annoncent que nous allions de
l'abandon du logiciel fou de paye
louvois il a cependant manqué selon nous
l'occasion d'adapter notre outil de
défense à nos priorités stratégiques
en effet le texte confirme le maintien
d'une force de dissuasion nucléaire qui
engagera à elle seule 23 3 milliards
d'euros de crédits pour la période 2014
2019 or il nous l'avons déjà signalé en
première lecture cette décision n'a fait
l'objet d'aucun débat en séance publique
avec nombre de nos collègues où nous
n'avons pas été non plus associé à
l'élaboration du livre plan d'une avons
signalé même si les travaux de la
commission ad-hoc furent sûrement riche
et de grande qualité nous ne le
connaissons pas nous nous étonnons que
notre stratégie nucléaire ne soient pas
débattues ici tous ensemble à défaut
d'être davantage remise en question
alors que de plus en plus de hauts
responsables politiques et militaires
s'interrogent ouvertement sur la
pertinence d'une force atomique aussi
coûteuse que désuète le contexte
international et géopolitique a
totalement changé depuis 1989 et nous
continuerons nous à nous cramponner sur
un dispositif anciens à l'identique qui
ne correspond plus à la vision qui nous
semble approprié au monde d'aujourd'hui
dans un contexte économique très
contraints nous considérons qu'il y a
urgence à mener une réflexion sur le
bien fondé du maintien de la force
nucléaire en l'état et nous sollicitons
un ajustement de la force de dissuasion
et certains parents nous souhaite sa
remise en cause totale paul quilès un
homme politique particulièrement
responsable ou un autre homme politique
très respectée ici comme l'ancien
premier ministre michel rocard pose
ouvertement la question tout comme le
précédent ministre de la défense hervé
morin a posé certaines questions
pourquoi ne pas garder la composante
sous-marine et faire en sorte que l'on
arrête par exemple dans dix ans la
composante aérienne ce qui nous ferait
faire des économies de l'ordre d'environ
1 à 25 milliards d'euros suivant les
estimations on pourrait utiliser cette
somme à la fois pour le désendettement
et pour renforcer nos unités
d'intervention sur le terrain dans le
cadre de nos engagements internationaux
confère notre débat de tout à l'heure
n'oublions pas non plus les engagements
de la france en matière de désarmement
notamment dans le cadre du traité de
non-prolifération
la france s'est engagée à poursuivre de
bonne foi des négociations sur des
mesures efficaces relatives à la
cessation de la course aux armements
nucléaires à une date rapprochée et au
désarmement nucléaire fin de la citation
quelles sont donc nos priorités
stratégiques en ce sens est il vraiment
aujourd'hui nécessaire de maintenir en
mer quatre sous marins lanceurs d'engins
et de conserver en parallèle une
coûteuse composantes composante
aéroportée nous ne le pensons pas il y a
là un déséquilibre dans le budget de
notre défense entre les crédits alloués
à la dissuasion et les moyens donnés à
nos forces conventionnelles qui nous
semble à interroger nous sommes
aujourd'hui un an et demi de la
conférence de révision du traité de
non-prolifération
échéance à laquelle la france devra bien
préciser sa politique de désarmement le
temps presse
ce projet de loi de programmation
militaire aurait pourtant été l'occasion
de débattre des priorités à donner à
notre outil de défense et cela
collectivement mon troisième point
portera monsieur le ministre sur le
dossier de l'indemnisation des victimes
des essais nucléaires particulièrement
cher aux sénateurs que vous avez cités
tout à l'heure si le dispositif
d'indemnisation a plus fortement évolué
lors de l'examen du texte au sénat et à
l'assemblée nationale et nous saluons
monsieur le ministre votre écoute et
celui de votre cabinet sur ce dossier
nous regrettons cependant que les
avancées soient toujours insuffisante
nous déplorons en effet que les demandes
et les situations souvent dit fille des
victimes soit analysée à la seule
lumière d'un modèle statistique analyse
qui conclut presque toujours un risque
négligeable
le logiciel non console eu non conçues
pour cela à l'origine démontre
finalement ce pourquoi il a été
programmé est choisi il ya là comme un
syllogisme vous le savez bien seulement
douze dossiers de demandes
d'indemnisation ont connu un sort
favorable alors que le comité d'amener
des indemnisations des victimes des
essais nucléaires civen a reçu près de
840 dossier dix sept ans après le
dernier essai nucléaire et près de trois
ans après la promulgation de la loi de
reconnaissance et l'indemnisation des
victimes des essais nucléaires dite loi
morin la france n'arrive pas indemnisés
ce qu'elle a exposé pourquoi ne pas
vouloir permettre un réel examen du
dossier au cas par cas et si le système
de présomption de causalité avec limite
était supprimée il ne faudrait pas
s'attendre à une multiplication des
mesures et de nouvelles demandes
d'indemnisation de la part des
personnels civils et militaires car
beaucoup d'entre eux sont hélas déjà
mort et il est très difficile pour les
survivants de faire le lien entre leur
maladie et leur participation aux essais
dont on avait affirmé jadis qu'il était
sans danger ou propres le tout est
désormais impropre nous le savons bien
et il faut aussi rappeler que les
crédits de paiement de 10 millions
d'euros pour l'indemnisation des
victimes des essais nucléaires ont été
maintenus par la mission anciens
combattants mémoire et liens avec la
nation du projet de loi de finances 2014
aussi l'article 40 qui a frappé notre
proposition nous interroge quelque peu
puisque les dix millions d'euros avaient
déjà été signalés mais à quoi bon ces 10
millions si le nombre d'indemnisés reste
toujours aussi faible enfin pour
terminer quant à l'article 13 nous
l'avons bien volontiers qui dans un
premier temps n'avait soulevé que notre
perplexité
nous pensons aujourd'hui qu'au vu de la
polémique qui s'ouvre à nous ils
n'offrent peut-être pas toutes les
garanties dans une démocratie telle que
nous la concevons nous la souhaitons
je vous remercie monsieur le monsieur le
président en commission au final
monsieur le ministre même si nous avons
pu tout à l'heure lors de la précédent
débat vous faire part d'un soutien
global pour l'action précis précités à
une exception près les sénateurs et
sénatrices écologistes ne pourront pas
voter ce texte là pour les raisons qui
ont été évoqués lors de ce propos je
vous remercie de votre attention merci
chers collègues la parole est à gérard
larcher
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur les présidents de
commissions mes chers collègues cet
après midi nous venons d'avoir un débat
sur la situation en république
centrafricaine et l'intervention de nos
soldats c'est la démonstration s'il en
était besoin que notre défense nationale
est bien le bras armé de notre
diplomatie c'est l'ultime preuve s'il en
fallait que notre défense nationale et
la première garantie de notre
crédibilité c'est le gage de notre siège
de membre permanent au conseil de
sécurité des nations unies
hasard du calendrier
le vote de la résolution 21-27 est
intervenue la veille du sommet de
l'elysée sommet pour la paix et la
sécurité en afrique en 1994 bientôt 20
ans
se tenait à biarritz un sommet franco
africain
l'initiative du président mitterrand où
il était déjà question de force
d'intervention rapide en afrique vingt
ans plus tard qu'en est il quelques
heures avant le vote d'une loi de
programmation qui d'ailleurs nous
apparaît sous dotées regard de nos
ambitions concrètes sur la scène
diplomatique
comme on fait les orateurs précédents je
veux rendre hommage au courage et au
comportement exemplaire de nos soldats
sur nos théâtres d'opération et nous
partageons tous l'hommage que le
président du sénat a rendu à nos deux
militaires tombés pour la paix à bangui
mais en cette fin d'après midi c'est la
réalité géopolitique qui nous rattrape
qui frappe au coeur du vote de cette loi
de programmation militaire la france par
ses valeurs par attachement à la paix
dans le monde ne veut et ne peut déroger
à ses obligations morales et
humanitaires
et pour assumer notre rôle sur la scène
internationale il faut que nous ayons
les moyens financiers humains et
industriel c'est d'ailleurs cette
équation aux inconnues multiples à
laquelle doit répondre une loi de
programmation militaire
certes vendredi le président de la
république a déclaré que l'afrique
devait assurer sa sécurité par elle même
force est de constater que les premiers
encore et toujours à être sur place pour
protéger les populations civiles ce sont
les soldats français aux côtés de
l'union africaine malgré les discours
vendredi dernier j'étais présent du
président barroso et van rompuy on ne
peut que constater l'absence sur le
terrain et pardonnez moi sur le terrain
de nos alliés européens qui laissent la
france seule en centrafrique à quelques
jours d'un sommet des chefs d'état
consacrée à la décence une fois de plus
comme lors de l'opération serval nos
alliés n'engage pas leurs forces sur
cette terre africaine qui pourtant et
jacques legendre le rappeler ne leur est
pas étrangère et avec lequel beaucoup de
pays ont des liens historiques culturels
et j'allais dire des liens qui vont au
delà de l'immédiateté alors que nulle
part mieux ne remet en cause de la
légitimité de cette opération pour
prévenir crimes de guerre et crimes que
contre l'humanité je reviendrai ni sur
la quantité des sur la qualité des
travaux réalisés dans notre commission
et puis plus d'un an ils sont
incontestables joueurs ont remercié le
président et nos collègues de toute
sensibilité et ils sont nombreux
présents cet après midi ici qui sont
engagées sur le dossier mais il me
paraît dommageable de voir que cette
nouvelle loi de programmation militaire
n'en bénéficiera qu'assez peu en dépit
de nos efforts de concertation qui ont
permis au projet de loi d'arriver à
l'assemblée nationale
cette loi de programmation militaire et
de fait avant même son adoption me
semble-t-il déjà dépassé par rapport aux
objectifs je sais monsieur le ministre
vous parcourez garnison et quartier
militaire ces derniers jours vous
préoccupe or et c'est indispensable et
urgent de la vie quotidienne de nos
militaires la lecture d'ailleurs le
l'ambiance au conseil supérieur de la
fonction militaire de juin démontre
cette nécessité mais dans le même temps
le gouvernement décide de vous priver de
plus de 820 millions d'euros sur la
femme la gestion de votre budget 2013
prétendument
sanctuarisés cette ponction sur le
budget de la défense imputent au quasi
totalité sur les crédits d'équipement
c'est 10%
du budget de crédits d'équipement
dissuasion heureusement sanctuarisés
vous avez dit pouvoir obtenir si besoin
des ressources exceptionnelles en 2014
pour compenser ce prélèvement mais d'où
viendront tél comment pourront elles
être utilisées puisque les contraintes
d'emplois de telles ressources sont
écrasantes est ce que la loi n'est pas
déjà caduc au travers de poura projet de
loi de finances rectificative et projet
de loi de finances et initial on
débutera 2014 avec un report de charge
financière de 4 milliards d'euros pour
le budget de la défense
7 un chiffre sans précédent
ce montant c'est un sommet de crédits
d'équipement hors dissuasion
comment peut-on parler devant nous d'une
lpm qui sera exécuté jusqu'au dernier
euro votez point d'interrogation face à
l'instabilité croissante de plusieurs
régions du monde nous déployons de plus
en plus de soldats et sur plusieurs
théâtres d'opérations simultanées cela
devrait nous conduire à tout le moins
une stabilisation de nos effectifs nous
n'ignorons pas la baisse des effectifs
de la précédente loi mais la salle est
dire la question mérite d'être posée ce
que je constate c'est que la défense
assure à elle seule
60 % des baisses d'effectifs de la
fonction publique est ce cohérent et
juste est juste pour reprendre les
propos du président de la république le
30 janvier dernier pour deux soldats
dans le professionnalisme et
l'engagement font la fierté de notre
pays en plus nous savons tous mais je
reviendrai pas sur les crédits opex nous
savons tous à des question qui est posée
aujourd'hui est le rapport de la cour
des comptes sur les crédits du budget de
l'état ouverte par acred avancée est à
citer les dépenses d'équipement joue
comme chaque année le rôle de variable
d'ajustement au profit de la masse
salariale et des opex alors qu'elles
étaient nécessaires pour respecter le
calendrier de la loi de programmation
militaire ce n'est pas le premier pc et
d'autres ont pêché avant vous et
pardonnez moi pardonnez moi le cumul
c'est quoi c'est une régression
conséquent de nos capacités
opérationnelles au travers du maintien
en condition opérationnelle
insuffisamment financé alors monsieur le
ministre
je suis pris par le temps et pourtant je
voudrais vous dire que certes on procède
un gymnaste hic budgétaire report de
crédit annulation bien sûr nous
reconnaissons l'action et le rôle qui a
été le vôtre et je vous en donne acte
avec parfois j'allais dire un regard
admiratif parce que je sais ce que c'est
de se battre pour des crédits mais je
voudrais redire ici
catéchisme en aux armées que nous
partageons ne rime pas nécessairement
avec consensus politique obligatoire sur
l'engagement des forces de nos forces à
l'étranger il peut y avoir consensus
c'est le cas aujourd'hui nous sommes
totalement côté de nos soldats sur les
moyens que nous devons y consacrer pour
les temps futurs il ne peut il peut ne
pas y avoir consensus et c'est
d'ailleurs pour ces raisons que le
groupe ump non sans regret votre à à
quelques exceptions près qui seront
l'expression d'abstention votre à très
majoritairement contre cette loi de
programmation militaire
je vous remercie merci monsieur larcher
la parole est à daniel renner pour le
groupe socialiste
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues nous
achevons ici un cycle commencé avec les
premières réunions de la commission du
livre blanc travail de longue haleine
que nous espérons voir se terminer ce
soir par le vote de cette nouvelle loi
de programmation militaire
les débats ont été longs mais intense
constructif et en tout cas utile ce fut
le cas au moment de l'élaboration du
nouveau livre blanc
de la défense et de la sécurité
nationale cela a été aussi vrai pendant
cette séquence parlementaire durant
laquelle notre modèle de défense a été
interrogé y compris sur les points les
plus sensibles comme la dissuasion
nucléaire
le livre blanc a fait un état des lieux
dressé un bilan sans concession des
faiblesses et des forces de notre modèle
de défense actualiser notre analyse
stratégique dégager de nouvelles
priorités
éconduit il conduit naturellement à cet
exercice de nature législative celui là
qu'est l'élaboration d'une loi de
programmation militaire
plus encore qu'à l'occasion du débat
autour du livre blanc ce autour de ce
set plm ont suscité de multiples
questions et ce fut de ce point de vue
un exercice véritablement démocratique
et enrichissant les deux chambres ont
apporté leur touche à l'exercice est
aujourd'hui un équilibre a été trouvé
sur ces points en discussion le sénat
grâce aux travaux préparatoires à
l'initiative du président carrère à
comment dirais-je conduit par notre
commission s'était préparé à cette
démarche il appuie ainsi apporter sa
contribution à ce nouvel acte de la
stratégie de défense nationale nos
collègues de l'assemblée nationale je
veux le dire ici on approfondit et
précisé nombre d'éléments de ce projet
je tiens à souligner que ces apports au
portant l'en compléter utilement
saluant je le pense
et collectivement le travail de
concertation entre les deux chambres
c'est assez rare et donc il faut les
saluer pour s'approprier et enrichir ce
texte de loi comme le sénat l'assemblée
a eu à coeur de sécuriser les ressources
financières c'est ainsi qu'elle a
approuvé un amendement du gouvernement
qui majore des recettes exceptionnelles
de 500 millions d'euros afin de
compenser les annulations de crédits du
dernier collectif
j'ai pourtant noté quelques divergences
mineures par exemple sur les
prérogatives de la délégation
parlementaire au renseignement
nous souhaitions que ces parlementaires
cette délégation puisse prendre
connaissance du plan national
d'orientation du renseignement ce n'est
plus le cas dans cette nouvelle version
du texte mais je note aussi que cela
correspond mieux ainsi au souhait de
certains d'entre nous sur les bancs de
cette assemblée sur la géolocalisation
des délais ont été ramenée à trente
jours une position intermédiaire entre
le gouvernement et le sénat et nous
regrettons enfin c'est un point que le
force de loi n'ait pas été donnée au
suivi médical et psychologique des
militaires revenant d'opération c'est un
sujet sensible et qui demeurera hélas
d'actualité
en revanche l'assemblée a complété le
texte sur plusieurs points
faire en sorte que les militaires
engagés en opex bénéficie de la carte du
combattant de façon effective
précisé le temps de travail des marins
mineurs
l'objectif étant de trouver un équilibre
satisfaisant entre les suggestions liés
aux obligations militaires la protection
des mineurs elle a également souhaité
conforter les droits des requérants
devant le comité d'indemnisation des
victimes des essais nucléaires
celui ci devra désormais motiver ses
réponses dans la partie annexe le sénat
avait par ces amendements souligné
l'impératif de rechercher des solutions
concrètes de mutualisation et de partage
d'acquisition et d'utilisation
d'équipements militaires à l'échelle
européenne
de préciser les effectifs en matière de
cyberdéfense de services de
renseignement tout cela était conservée
l'assemblée nationale a elle souhaité
rénover le dialogue social en incluant
volet sur la concertation d'amy deere ce
dernier point devrait permettre
d'améliorer encore une expression
sociale particulièrement nécessaire au
moment où se prépare de nouvelles
déflation d'effectifs et un remaniement
de la carte des implantations militaires
et je n'ose pas parler ici du trop
fameux logiciel louvois il y aurait trop
a dit la loi de programmation est un
édifice qui repose sur des bases nous le
savons fragile même parfois sur des
paris le projet de loi de finances
rectificative qui a abouti à
l'annulation de 500 millions d'euros de
crédits vient de le prouver un devoir de
vigilance repose donc sur les
parlementaires nous sommes donnés dans
cette loi des moyens supplémentaires de
contrôle nous les utiliserons
cette vigilance portera sur la mise en
oeuvre des fondamentaux de cette défense
nationale notre dissuasion et nos
capacités projection ils sont
sanctuarisés pour que la france puisse
honorer ses responsabilités vis-à-vis à
la fois de nos concitoyens et de nos
alliés
la définition du modèle d'armée 2025
conforme à la fois nos ambitions de
défense et à nos moyens financiers cela
demande un effort supplémentaire de
rationalisation et donc de nouveaux
sacrifices vingt-trois mille
suppressions de postes en plus des 54
milles de la précédente loi pour
justement sauvegarder l'essentiel
dissuasion capacité d'agir et permettre
à nos militaires d'accomplir à la fois
l'émission et permanents et non
permanents la révision réaliste de nos
contrats opérationnels qui répondent aux
menaces prévisible à l'échelle de la
durée de la loi en particulier le
maintenir notre capacité de projection
dans le cadre des opérations de
coercition en hauteur de 15 mille hommes
et d'intervention sur plusieurs théâtres
nous l'éprouvons aujourd'hui encore avec
notre double intervention actuelle au
mali et en centrafrique et permettez moi
aussi de saluer la mémoire de nos deux
combattants tombés au champ d'honneur
nous étions avec jacques gauthier au 8e
rpima ya pas très longtemps et nous y
avait merveilleusement accueilli
notre capacité maintenu à être leader
d'une coalition et entré en premier sur
des théâtres d'opération le maintien
d'une base industrielle de défense de
qualité et ce en dépit on le sait de
l'étalement de nos grands programmes par
ailleurs vous avez su dégager des
priorités d'être apparaissent
concrètement dans la programmation la
cyber défense en particulier dont il les
nul besoin d'illustrer ici la nécessité
la reconnaissance c'est l'anticipation
et pour paraphraser vladimir nabokov
littérature ne nuit pas science et
connaissance arrêt anticipation les 2
couples qui se cachent bien des choses
mais quand ils se comprennent rien au
monde ne les surpasse la france va donc
continuer à renforcer et ses services de
renseignements en temps nos hommes qu'en
matériel et vous savez bien que je pense
en particulier aux drones la recherche
et la technologie je ne n'ai pas entendu
aujourd'hui pour garder un temps
d'avancé sur les technologies clés et de
ce point de vue le montant des plans
d'études amont affiché en hausse
témoigne de cette volonté
l'entraînement bon niveau des personnels
l'entretien programmé le maintien en
condition opérationnelle des matériels
qui bénéficient des crédits a crû de
sorte que finalement les crédits
consacrés aux équipements seront en
sensible augmentation par rapport à la
loi de programmation précédente la
question d'un soutien de qualité est
essentielle
partagez intelligemment entre services
de l'état et industrie andry trouver à
la fois source d'efficacité source
d'économies de même qu'il faudra
rechercher là aussi la mutualisation
avec d'autres pays d'europe et j'ai
présent à l'esprit un cas d'école il est
d'actualité le soutien de l'a400m nous
avons travaillé cette question dans un
rapport au sénat avec nos collègues
bertrand auban et jacques gauthier cet
avion vient d'entrer en service chez
nous il entrera en service en septembre
prochain en grande-bretagne personne ne
peut croire et je ne peux pas l'imaginer
que nous ne parvenions pas à nous mettre
d'accord pour réaliser un soutien
partagé avec nos amis anglais ce serait
le gage d'un soutien plus large encore
dans le futur avec les autres futurs
utilisateurs européens dans le cas
contraire ce serait un échec pour le bon
sens en résumé monsieur mise ce texte
donne les moyens à la défense de
poursuivre nos efforts dans l'ensemble
de ses domaines qui nous permettront de
rester dans le peloton de tête des
puissances militaires celle qui compte
aujourd'hui dans le monde et partout
reconnu pourtant nous le savons nous
sommes en présence d'un édifice fragile
qu'il s'agit de préserver pour ce faire
nous avons souhaité sénat et assemblée
nationale instauré une clause de
revoyure fin 2015 et un contrôle quasi
permanent car nous pensons important que
la représentation nationale soit
étroitement associé à la mise en oeuvre
de la programmation militaire monsieur
le ministre en conclusion vous avez
souhaité faire oeuvre de vérité et de
réalisme avec cette loi vous avez
inscrit votre réflexion votre action
dans une perspective financière qui
contribue pour sa part au redressement
des comptes publics parce qu'il en va de
la souveraineté de notre pays vous avez
bénéficié de l'engagement et de la
décision du président de la république
chef des armées de sanctuariser des
crédits qu la nation consent pour
assurer sa protection et permettre à
notre pays de tenir son rang dans le
concert des nations vous pouvez compter
sur nous nous serons à vos côtés pour
veiller à la mise en oeuvre de cette loi
est peut-être pour une fois faire en
sorte qu'elle respecte ses engagements
naturellement et vous l'avez compris le
groupe socialiste apportera son soutien
à votre loi de programmation militaire
je vous remercie vous remercie chers
collègues la parole est un jeanny
lorgeoux du groupe socialiste
madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
je ne sais pas cher michelle demessine
ce qu'est une défense national
progressiste
je ne connais que la défense nationale
aussi vais-je évoqué brièvement
l'un de ses piliers la sécurité
extérieure
parce que la dgse est à la fois un
service de renseignement extérieur qui
recherchent au dehors
des informations confidentielles
intéressant la sécurité nationale
qu'elle est un service spécial assurant
une présence là où les canaux
diplomatiques s'arrête et où le secret
constitue la protection des agents
qu'elle est un service intégré
qui maîtrise le spectre complet des
modes de recueil du renseignement
sur fumel
capteurs technique
intercepteurs
électromagnétiques et imagerie
satellitaire moyens opérationnels
exploitation des sources ouvertes et
bien pour cette raison
il était indispensable que la lpm consac
son rôle fondamental dans la protection
de la nation
la lpm prévoit une enveloppe cumulé de
dépenses d'investissement pour le
renseignement de 3 milliards 4,2 euros
pour la période 2014 2019 dont un
milliard deux pour la dgse
cela inclut la mise en oeuvre de grands
programmes de renseignement satellitaire
avec deux satellites d'observation
spatiale musis
le satellite de renseignement
électromagnétique crs
les drones male vous en avez parlé et
les drones tactiques
ainsi que la modernisation des capacités
techniques de recueil et de traitement
de l'information
nous apprécions que la lpm traduisent en
actes
les lignes du livre blanc et qu'elle
érige le renseignement en priorité
majeure à cet égard il était crucial à
nos yeux
d'inscrire dans la loi la poursuite de
la hausse des effectifs
de l'ordre de trois sons et des moyens
de la dg ce malgré un contexte global de
réduction des effectifs du ministère de
la défense
cet effort singulier est d'autant plus
appréciable car retards importants
avaient été pris naguère
tandis que le service doit répondre de
nouveaux défis liés des évolutions
technologiques
induisant des nouvelles menaces il a été
évoqué la cyber par exemple il faut
rappeler que les crédits et les
effectifs ne représente que 2% des
crédits effectifs du ministère et sont
donc en deçà de ceux dont disposent par
exemple la grande bretagne ou
l'allemagne
en outre monsieur le ministre nous
apprécions qu'un point d'équilibré et
ait été trouvé entre deux couples de
nécessité contradictoires premièrement
celui d'une part de renforcer le
contrôle parlementaire en élargissant
les prérogatives de la délégation
parlementaire au renseignement et celui
d'autre part de protéger l'anonymat de
nos agents pour assurer leur sécurité
et deuxièmement celui d'une part de
renforcer notre sécurité nationale y
compris en accédant à des données de
connexion
et par la géolocalisation en temps réel
au demeurant de manière strictement
encadrée et celui d'autre part de
sauvegarder nos libertés individuels à
cet égard
l'article 13 a pour objet d'en pc des
actes terroristes et non de s'insinuer
dans la sphère intime de la vie privée
comme son nom l'indiqué big browser
renvoie au delà de l'atlantique
c'est là que l' angoisse numérique doit
s'exprimer si elle doit s'exprimer
enfin je terminerai ce coup de
projecteur très furtif
en rendant hommage à la mémoire de denis
allex tomber en somalie après un long
calvaire
et aux 5000 personnels civils et
militaires de la dgse
dans le travail méconnu
souterrain et périlleux est essentielle
à la défense des intérêts de la france
comme c'est le cas notamment en afrique
hier comme aujourd'hui
nous vous remercions monsieur le
ministre d'avoir y compris dans ce
domaine investi résolument pour l'avenir
merci chers collègues
la parole est à notre collègue andré
trillard du groupe ump
monsieur le président monsieur la
défense mes chers collègues aujourd'hui
la france est engagée militairement sur
un nouveau théâtre d'opération c'est
tout naturellement que les premières
pensées vont à nos soldats dont nous
connaissons l'engagement et le
professionnalisme et je tiens aussi à
saluer tout particulièrement le courage
et le sacrifice de nos deux soldats
tombés au combat
je ne reviendrai pas sur le détail des
crédits alloués à chaque programme car
certains de mes collègues le ferons
mieux que je ne le ferai je pense à
jacques gauthier et xavier pintât qui
n'ont pas ménagé leur peine pour que cet
lp m puis s'éloigner du scénario du pire
ou du moins pire
je souhaite aussi rappeler que la
commission elle non plus n'a pas ménagé
ses efforts ni ses publications ni les
signaux d alerte auprès du gouvernement
je pense notamment la conférence de
presse organisée à l'initiative du
président carrère le 13 mars dernier
lequel à juste titre ceux des siennes
l'apostrophent de danton en 1792 en
déclarant qu' aujourd'hui la patrie est
en danger car sa défense l'est il
ajoutait je suis en effet convaincu que
notre sécurité sur les compromis si les
mesures de réduction de l'effort de
défense envisagée était adopté c'est
tout le sens de la démarche de
rassemblement du sénat que nous avons
entreprises pour ses propos pour votre
pugnacité pour cette démarche collective
de responsabilité sectorielle je
souhaite monsieur le président vous
remercier
cependant sept mois plus tard les
chiffres ont parlé d'eux mêmes oui
monsieur le ministre c'est bien dommage
il est bien dommageable que les travaux
parlementaires du sénat n'est pas plus
inspiré vous même votre collègue du
budget plutôt pour que soient alloués de
réels moyens la défense nationale après
plus d'une année de mobilisation
force est de constater non sans regret
que le résultat est assez décevant
décevant parce que entre la publication
du livre blanc et le vote qu'elle nous
procéderons dans quelques instants la
seule constance gouvernementale réside
dans la communication je ne reviendrai
pas sur les modifications et autres
reports de crédits car la défense n'est
pas fait seulement deux chiffres et de
programmes en même temps nous avons
assisté à une surenchère totalement
verbal en faveur de la puissance
technologique la réduction des budgets
voudrait nous faire croire qu'on peut
s'engager sur des théâtres d'opération
avec moins d'hommes
à condition qu'il soit sûr équipé mais
nous devons avoir les moyens de soutenir
tactiquement et logistiquement personne
ne reviendra sur la priorité absolue que
nous devons accorder aux drones la
technologie n'est rien si le
professionnalisme et la réactivité des
hommes ne sont pas au rendez vous la
défense sont d'abord et avant tout des
femmes et des hommes dont l'engagement
pour la nation dépasse de loin les
politiques partisanes appelle le respect
ce respect et cette gratitude doivent
trouver d'autres formes d'expression que
celle du recueillement devant le
monument aux morts qui ne suffit pas
tout à fait tant que parlementaire il ne
revient d'inscrire dans la loi les
conditions de cette reconnaissance la
traduire dans les réalités et les
contingences du quotidien
ainsi lorsque nous apprenons que le
paiement des indemnités de service en
campagne de 2013 pourrait ne pourrait
être effectuée qu'en 2014 devoir est de
réagir qu'en serait-il si cette
situation se produisait pour d'autres
corps de fonctionnaires
nous devons prendre la mesure des
changements structurels identitaire nous
sommes auxquelles nos armées sont
confrontés le turnover issus de la
professionnalisation introduit une
distorsion entre les officiers
supérieurs aux longues carrières et des
soldats engagés aux contrats courts
cela implique une gestion des ressources
humaines novatrices pour d'une part
fidéliser les sous-officiers et de
l'autre des pyramides et nous ne pouvons
d'autre part à tombes de soldats qu'ils
soient motivés bien formés prêt au
sacrifice avec toujours moins de moyens
et d matériel vieillissant
alors dans cet environnement où la
confiance
n'est plus où les hommes savoie se
l'appliqué sens de la route du travail
le ministre vous avez accepté assemblée
création d'une section consacrée au
dialogue social il est nécessaire que
les militaires puissent obtenir un
relais
est une véritable prise en compte des
problèmes qu'ils rencontrent au
quotidien face aux difficultés de leur
métier à cet égard il apporterait soit
créée par le ministère une cellule
d'écouté des choses pour entendre gérer
en plus de la fonction publique
qui est
que je ne critique pas l'organisme que
je ne critique pas mais ce malaise qui
se trouve aujourd'hui dans le dans le
dans l'armée il ne faut pas le résoudre
avec une arme d'apparat quel dialogue
social appelé aussi la société civile
syndicats les ce we les militants ont
besoin d espace de parole mais
uniquement au sein des armées et pour
elle si vous ne préserver pas cette
spécificité c'est la fin des armées en
tant qu'institution si des officiers
sont sortis du rang pour nous alerter
leur situation c'est d'abord et avant
tout parce qu'il souhaite plus de moyens
pour exercer leurs missions
je ne dois pas d'attirer votre attention
sur le point suivant qui me semble
important les contraintes économiques
ont vu naître une compétition militaires
et industrielles pour les dotations
publiques ainsi qu'une concurrence de
plus ou plus de plus en plus ouverts
contre les trois armes
ceci est dangereux pour l'institution
pour son fonctionnement et pour sa
cohésion au sein de nos hémicycle tel
paraît soutenir plus tard mais terre
telle autre défendre l armée de l'air ou
la marine représentants de la nation ne
devons nous garder de ses tentations et
avoir pour seul objectif l'unité et la
puissance de nos armées
monsieur le ministre avec le chef de
l'état vous en êtes les premiers garants
car la responsabilité des politiques qui
à la globalité est à la hauteur de vue
je vais arrêter mon propos pour tenir
compte des demandes de la présidente je
vais juste dire que en toute conscience
je voterai contre 7 elle perd je mens
merci chers collègues la parole était
andré vallini du groupe socialiste
la présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues notre environnement
stratégique est de plus en plus
incertain et si des conflits change de
visage il autorise aucun relâchement
dans notre politique de sécurité et de
défense c'est pourquoi la france n'a
jamais cessé d'être vigilante et qu'elle
prend ses responsabilités chaque fois
que cela s'avère nécessaire elle le
montre au mali depuis bientôt un an et
elle le prouve en république
centrafricaine depuis la semaine
dernière
lors d'un déplacement à l'onu la
commission des affaires étrangères en
octobre dernier nous avons pu mesurer
avec christian cambon leila aichi et
jean marie bockel à quel point dans les
milieux internationaux ont fait souvent
la différence entre la pusillanimité de
barack obama sur la syrie et la
réactivité de françois hollande sur le
mali j'ajoute que si les français savait
mieux que ce n'est le cas aujourd'hui
l'image de la france sur la scène
internationale il serait beaucoup plus
fiers de leur pays qu'ils ne le sont
parfois alors pour que la france reste
digne de son histoire et du site face à
son avenir la loi de programmation
militaire dont nous parlons ce soir va
lui garantir les capacités nécessaires
pour assurer sa sécurité
comme ses responsabilités
internationales c'est un texte
d'équilibré
qui modernise notre modèle de défense en
l'adaptant aux nouvelles donnes
stratégique et qui permet à la france de
respecter ses engagements internationaux
tout en assumant ses trois missions
fondamentales la protection du
territoire la dissuasion et la capacité
d'intervention extérieure
mais si tout ça est possible
c'est évidemment au prix d'un effort
budgétaire très important pour la france
monsieur le ministre nous débattrons
demain dans cet hémicycle de l'europe de
la défense nous aurons l'occasion de
vous dire et vous le savez que pendant
que le monde est en train de réarmer je
pense à la chine à l'inde au brésil la
russie l'europe elle ne doit pas désarmé
le sommet européen de la semaine
prochaine doit donc être l'occasion de
relancer l'europe de la défense en
adoptant une feuille de route dans les
domaines opérationnels
capacitaire industriels et même
institutionnels
il faut des mesures pragmatiques bien
sûr mais il faut aussi une vision et une
ambition pour que l'europe ne se résume
pas un grand marché elle doit avoir une
défense autonome si elle souhaite
devenir enfin une grande puissance à
l'échelle du monde mais en attendant
l'europe de la défense la france ne peut
continuer à faire autant d'efforts sans
que ces efforts soient reconnus par ses
partenaires européens y compris au plan
budgétaire
c'est en effet au nom de nos valeurs
communes que nous allons combattre au
mali ou en centrafrique et c'est dans
l'intérêt de l'europe toute entière que
nous sommes intervenus en libye où que
nous pourrions demain agir en syrie cet
effort notamment financier n'est pas
reconnu comme il convient par l'europe
d'autres l'ont dit avant moi cet après
midi le président carrère jean pierre
chevènement françois rebsamen nous
devons donc agir pour que bruxelles
desserrent l'étau de nos finances
publiques en déduisant les dépenses
militaires du calcul du déficit autorisé
cette déduction pour être partielle bien
sûr elle serait à définir en fonction de
critères a précisé je pense par exemple
un pourcentage de pipe qu'on pourrait
prendre en compte pourcentage de pipe
consacré à la défense
d'autres solutions existent je sais que
c'est difficile vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure mais chez le ministre en réponse
à françois rebsamen mais il faut
absolument aller dans cette direction
car il est plus facile pour certains
pays d'être exemplaire sur le plan
budgétaire
compétitive sur le plan industriel
excédentaires sur le plan commercial
quand on est passif pour ne pas dire
inexistant sur la scène internationale
monsieur le ministre la france assume
trop souvent seul le rôle qu'on serait
en droit d'attendre de l'europe qu'elle
en soit au moins gratifié par nos amis
européens et pas seulement sous la forme
de beaux discours je vous remercie merci
chers collègues
la parole est à jacques gauthier du
groupe ump
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues nous voulons donc
réunies pour l'examen en seconde lecture
du projet de loi de programmation
militaire
examen dans lequel notre sénat saisi en
premier s'est beaucoup investi et en
tout premier lieu notre président de
commission jean louis carrère dont je
salue le travail et la passion très
rapidement six observations
premièrement nos collègues députés ont
su dans l'ensemble compléter de façon
judicieuse notre contribution sans la
dénaturer je m'en réjouis et les en
remercie de la même façon ce salut mon
collègue et ami daniel renner qui a
effectué précieux travail de liaison
entre les deux chambres à des fins
d'explication un travail si précieux mes
chers collègues du reste que nous
devrions nous inspirer à l'avenir pour
d'autres textes deuxièmement les députés
ont adopté à l'initiative du
gouvernement un amendement qui complète
la trajectoire financière de l'apn de
500 millions d'euros si nécessaire
cela va bien sûr dans le bon sens nous
savons monsieur le ministre que c'est
votre engagement personnel qui a permis
d'arracher ce complément et je salue
votre action mais nous ne sommes pas dû
la recette était incertaine 2014 2015 le
combat va continuer avec bercy ce qui
m'amène à ma troisième observation le
report de charges il a atteint cette
année 3,6 milliards d'euros 3,1 si on
intègre notamment demandé 2014 dans 2,1
milliards pour le seul programme 146 le
tout en forte augmentation
le ministère de la défense a toujours
connu des reports de charges mais nous
atteignons un sommet si je m'en tiens
aux rapports successifs de la commission
des finances de l'assemblée nationale
pour les divers plf rapport qui n'ont
jamais été démentis je trouve 1 7
milliard d'euros de reports de charges
fin 2009 seulement 719 millions d'euros
fin 2010 à nouveau 1,5 milliard fin 2011
1,7 milliard fin 2012 et 3 ou 3 6 cette
année
cette explosion n'est pas supportable il
sera nécessaire comme c'est prévu dans
la lpm d'apporter des réponses
budgétaires lors de la clause de
revoyure de 2015 pour au moins monsieur
le ministre réduire sensiblement cette
bosse et les ministères pouce devant lui
4e observation cette clause de revoyure
sera d'autant plus essentielle que vous
devrez en plus de ce report de charges
prendre des décisions en ce qui concerne
les avions ravitailleurs
vous l'avez évoqué les drones les
rafales en fonction l'export et un
certain nombre de programmes nécessaires
à la force je pense aux missiles et aux
munitions je souhaite monsieur le
ministre de toute heure dans l'intérêt
de notre pays que la reprise économique
soit au rendez-vous et qu'elle vous
donne des moyens de corriger la
trajectoire de cette terre si
malheureusement ce n'était pas le cas
vous devriez alors faire face à la
réalité et à mon avis la seule option
possible passera par des cessions
d'actifs comme je le proposais à travers
de mes amendements première lecture
faute de quoi nous devrions alors faire
le deuil de la lpm hainaut tout il
défend serait gravement au béret 5e
remarque cela a été dit après le mali la
france intervient sous mandat des
nations unies en république
centrafricaine
nous en avons parlé cet après midi je
m'en félicite vendredi dernier au sommet
de l'elysée le secrétaire général de
l'onu le président barroso et bien
d'autres ont félicité la france les
nations unies et l'union européenne ont
promis des soutiens financiers et
logistiques pour la force africaine
parfait mais encore une fois c'est la
france qui intervient sur le t1 c'est
elle qui paiera équipe est déjà le prix
de la sueur et du sang il est temps à
quelques jours du sommet européen sur la
défense d'obtenir cela était demandé
soit l'envoi des groupements tactiques à
nos côtés soit des compensations y
compris financières sixième et dernière
remarque enfin mais cela dépasse
ministère de la défense et concerne
l'ensemble du budget de l'état au niveau
du pf 2014 bercy a décidé au 1er janvier
prochain le gel de sept pour cent des
crédits votés par nos assemblées soit
300 millions d'euros puisse du
supplémentaire puisque l'an dernier ce
gel était limitée à 6% c'est bien la
preuve que bercy ne tablent pas sur un
retour de la croissance cela pose aussi
la question de la sincérité de la
véracité des budgets qui sont votées
dans nos assemblées il faudra bien qu'un
jour les gouvernements par delà nos
différences
réfléchissent à une mise à plat du
fonctionnement budgétaire pour plus de
transparence et de véracité comme devons
le faire dans les communes et des
collectivités territoriales
monsieur le ministre je m'étais abstenu
en première lecture de ses textes
aujourd'hui l'assemblée nationale n'a
pas dénaturé notre travail la compléter
et votre amendement de 500 millions
d'euros même insuffisant va dans le bon
sens mais cette loi cela a été dit
demeure fragile et de nombreuses
incertitudes demeurent et parfois
s'aggrave pourtant ce n'est pas au
moment où des milliers de soldats
français sont déployés en opex parfois
dans des conditions dangereuses comme au
mali ou en centrafrique que je peux
voter contre cet lp m pour moi votez
contre serait pire pour notre armée et
pour nos industries de défense kerry
s'est passé un texte a minima est
insuffisant je m'abstiendrai donc
monsieur ministre comme certains de mes
collègues en rêvant au moins en matière
de défense d'une grande coalition à
l'allemande ou nous pourrions ensemble
un amant faire les meilleurs choix pour
les armées et notre outil de défense
je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
gilbert rouge et du groupe socialiste
monsieur le madame la présidente pardon
monsieur le ministre chers collègues
conformément aux engagements du
président de la république et malgré un
contexte économique et budgétaire que
nous rappelons les uns et les autres
extrêmement difficile l'effort consacré
par la nation à sa défense sera
maintenue au niveau
significatif entre 2014 et 2019 les
ressources du ministère
s'élèveront à 190 milliards d'euros
courants en sanctuarisant le budget de
la défense nationale le président a fait
le choix de maintenir un niveau
d'ambition élevé sur la scène
internationale à la hauteur des besoins
et les responsabilités de notre pays il
faut rappeler que peu de pays dans le
monde peuvent comme la france se
prévaloir d'une armée capable d'assumer
les trois missions fondamentales que
sont la protection du territoire
national et de la population une
dissuasion nucléaire à deux composants
et l'intervention sur des théâtres
extérieurs
depuis le précédent livre blanc de 2008
le contexte a connu des évolutions
majeures avec notamment les conséquences
que l'on sait de la crise économique et
financière
ainsi le projet de lpm tout en
maintenant l'effort consacré par la
nation à sa défense a dû prendre en
compte l'objectif de redressement des
finances publiques dont la dégradation
est devenu en elle-même un ange de
souveraineté et par conséquent afin de
dégager les marges de manoeuvre
budgétaires nécessaires pour que la
france conserve son rang sur la scène
internationale le projet de loi prolonge
jeu de façon modérée la réduction du
format de nos armées avec la suppression
de 23 mille cinq cents emplois entre
2014 et 2019 cette déflation d'effectifs
qui se fait en cohérence avec la refonte
des contrats opérationnels et de
l'objectif fixé par le livre blanc de
2013 et assortie d'un large plan de
mesures d'accompagnement du personnel
civil et militaire
appelée à quitter le service et je
souhaite une attention soit portée plus
particulièrement sur le long terme à
l'accompagnement social économique et
territorial du nouveau format de l'armée
définit par ce livre blanc
cette manoeuvre de ressources humaines
ambitieux s'inscrit dans le contexte
rendu difficile par les insuffisances du
système louvois nous en avons parlé et
je tiens à souligner les décision
courageuse du ministre de la défense
jean yves le drian de remplacer ce
système informatique nous l'avons évoqué
la définition du nouveau format d'armé
ainsi que les efforts d'économie
consentis par le ministère de la défense
supposerons une optimisation du plan de
stationnement du ministère dans un souci
de mutualisation des soutiens de
densification des emprises et de
réduction des dépenses de fonctionnement
la lpm prévoit une enveloppe de 150
millions d'euros pour l'accompagnement
économique sur la période 2014 2019 sur
le principe de contractualisation niveau
local dans un souci d'efficience des
fonds et d'équité vis-à-vis des
collectivités
il est indispensable d'expliciter sur
les terrains les mesures prévues pour
accompagner les restructurations
dans les territoires les plus fragiles
et vous avez commencé ce travail
monsieur le ministre c'était fort
pédagogique
il est nécessaire aussi pour le moral
des troupes
qui ont déjà consenti de par le passé de
nombreux efforts en interarmées sur la
mutualisation la rationalisation des
dispositifs de soutien
ainsi l' annonce faite par le ministère
de le 25 octobre dernier de débloquer
immédiatement des fonds à hauteur de 30
millions d'euros pour les bases de
défense qui ciblent prioritairement les
dépenses concrètes
équipements réfection de locaux
facilitée a été accueilli avec un
soulagement par les militaires un sujet
d'inquiétude demeure pourtant c'est la
question des gels de crédits nous
l'avons évoqué des 820 millions qui
risque de manquer aux armées en 2014 si
les crédits ne sont pas des gelées c'est
toute la programmation militaire qui
risque de voler en éclats et monsieur le
ministre vous aviez annoncé le 15
novembre dernier un accord trouvé avec
bercy nous aimerions donc que vous
puissiez s'il vous plaît précisiez quel
est le sort réservé sur ces gels de 820
millions enfin chers collègues pour
conclure je souhaiterais vous faire part
de ma satisfaction sur la façon dont se
sont déroulés les débats tant ici au
sénat qu'à l'assemblée nationale autour
de ce projet de lpm démontrant la
capacité de la représentation nationale
a adopté des choix stratégiques pour la
nation dans un consensus trans partisan
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
la parole est à notre collègue xavier
pintât du groupe ump
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le vote
d'une loi de programmation militaire est
un moment important dans la vie d'une
législature nous devons tout faire pour
préserver la valeur de nos forces armées
respectez les hommes et les femmes qui
les composent préserver la qualité des
équipements dont ils disposent et
veiller à la préparation qu'ils
reçoivent nous devons tout faire pour
préserver cela jusque et y compris pour
éviter de nous quereller car il y va de
l'intérêt de la nation
alors que penser de ce projet de loi tel
qu'il nous revient de l'assemblée
nationale premièrement que l'assemblée
n'a que peu modifié ce projet ça a été
dit et a conservé la quasi totalité des
acquis du sénat dont acte on peut saluer
le travail de notre commission en
première lecture sous l'impulsion
efficace du président carrère j'observe
cependant que l'assemblée nationale a
supprimé le seul apport du groupe ump du
sénat la modification du calendrier de
livraison des avions ravitailleurs
lorsqu'on recherche le consensus trans
partisan c'est peut-être dommage même si
nous avons pris acte de votre
déclaration initiale deuxièmement nous
apprenons entre les deux lecture de ce
texte qu'il y aurait un report de
charges de l'exercice 2013 sur de
l'exercice 2014 de 3,6 milliards d'euros
ce report de charge n'a jamais été aussi
important ça a été rappelé par jacques
gauthier puisqu'il n'était que de 1,5
milliards fin 2011
surtout et c'est cela qui est grave ce
report des charges n'est pas à l'heure
où nous délibérons compensées par des
ouvertures de crédit autant le dire tout
de suite cette loi de programmation ne
pourra pas être respecté
il m'a du reste fallu faire des
recherches par moi-même élire votre
propre interview monsieur le ministre de
la défense sur le blog de la tribune.fr
pour connaître le montant exact du
report de charges 3,6 milliards il
aurait été préférable de le lire dans un
rapport officiel je sais ce que vous
pouvez nous dire c'est que les 500
millions votés à l'assemblée nationale
sont une garantie mais on a parfois
entendu trop de promesses
gouvernementales de tous bords
d'ailleurs pour ignorer que parfois les
promesses n'engagent que ceux qui les
écoutent
si vous aviez gagné l'arbitrage
cet amendement saurait dans le projet de
loi de finances or il n'y est pas après
ces deux constats ayant le courage de
regarder la vérité en face la vérité est
que la précédente majorité auquel
j'appartenais à fait passer l'effort de
défense de 1,75 du pib à 1,5
ce que je regrette elle a réduit le
format de nos forces armées en faisant
partager l'idée que 1,5 pour cent du pib
était le plancher minimum à ne pas
dépasser la vérité aussi et que la
majorité actuelle je crois se bercent
d'illusions en invoquant un retour à
meilleure fortune à 1,8 pour cent du pib
et en croyant à des clauses de garanties
la vérité que l'effort de défense notre
pays va passer de 1 5% en 2013 non pas à
1 3% comme on l'espérait encore il ya un
mois mais à 1,1 en 2010 neuf puisque
l'on sait maintenant que la
programmation ne pourra pas être
respecté
encore une fois il ne s'agit pas à
monsieur le ministre de vous mettre en
cause vous savez bien l'estiment que
notre commission vous portent à la fois
votre personne mais aussi pour votre
engagement mais le cesi s'il est encore
temps et que nous en sommes encore
capables de comprendre les raisons de
cette mécanique implacable qui a conduit
le gouvernement je devrais dire tous les
gouvernements à réduire l'effort de
défense sept ans sénateur convaincu que
la défense est l'ultime garant de notre
liberté que je me suis efforcé de
comprendre les raisons de cette
situation et les réponses que j'ai
trouvés sont au nombre de 2 d'abord la
défense est par définition la grande
muette c'est bien ainsi d'ailleurs mais
il faut que nous soyons raisonnables on
ne peut pas reporter l'entier fardeau
des ajustements budgétaires sur les
forces armées au seul prétexte qu'elle
ne dirons rien aucune administration de
l'état n'a autant été saigné à blanc
aucune accepterait ce que les armées ont
accepté si on veut éviter que le
désespoir gagne nos armées il nous faut
nous parlementaires de tous bords nous
mobiliser tous ensemble pour la défense
et pour vous aider monsieur le ministre
a obtenu des arbitrages qu on vous
refuse la deuxième réponse je le vois
dans la sphère du report de crédit la
suite malheureuse de ce qui s'est passé
lors de la commission du livre blanc
c'est un secret pour personne je crois
qu'on n'a jamais fourni aux membres de
la commission l'équation budgétaire
c'est-à-dire le montant des moyens mis à
disposition des armées et cela continue
avec lpm car le report de crédit
devraient être intégrés dans la
construction budgétaire et ne pas
constituer un aléa de plus en plus
insupportable pour le budget de la
défense c'est pourquoi il nous faut
desserrer la contrainte financière
certains plaident pour la vente ne
partie non stratégiques de nos
participations dans les entreprises de
défense considérant que cet argent
serait mieux investi dans la recherche
dans l'emploi au service des
exportations quand stérile e
participation dont tout le monde a pu
constater d'une utilité dans la sphère b
à e eads d'autres croient aux marges
susceptible d'être dégagés par le choix
d'une défense intelligente à l'otan ou
de mutualisation en europe bowling
schering pour mettre fin aux gaspillages
inutiles nous devons priorité consacré
concentrer nos investissements sur nos
besoins capacitaires commun donc oui une
autre politique est possible et pour y
parvenir la confiance sera déterminante
je voudrais si vous le permettez pour
terminer relayer la vive émotion
suscitée par la nouvelle rédaction de
l'article 13 auprès des internautes qui
s'expriment largement dans les médias
depuis 48 heures il n'est pas
souhaitable sans expertise au préalable
dans un pays qui se veut exemplaire en
matière de protection des libertés des
droits de l'homme de proposé de
généraliser des interceptions
administratives et de permettre aux
services de l'état d'accéder à tous les
documents stockés dans les serveurs des
fournisseurs d'accès internet comme des
hébergeurs dans les disques durs dans
les icloud bien au delà des seules
données de géolocalisation objet initial
de l'article 13 de tels pouvoirs même
sous contrôle pensez à l'époque pour les
télécommunications non pour le numérique
déborde largement de la lutte contre le
terrorisme et me semble disproportionné
au regard des libertés individuelles
pour toutes les raisons que je viens
d'évoquer en ce qui me concerne
contrairement ma position en première
lecture que je ne regrette pas car on ne
s'oppose pas à priori à une loi de
programmation militaire et pour sonner
l'alarmé se ne voterait pas ce texte
je vous remercie monsieur ne l'aviez pas
mes chers collègues je vous remercie
d'avoir respecté le temps de parole
imparti à chacun cela me permet de
donner la parole à notre rapporteur
spécial puisque la transition est fait
avec l'article 13 pour avis
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je voulais
dire quelques mots à propos de l'article
13 en ma qualité de rapporteur pour avis
de la commission des lois et cela sera à
la suite des propos de notre collègue
pintât je tiens à dire ici avec beaucoup
de force suite aux campagnes qui se sont
développées depuis quelques jours que
nous avons voté cet article ici dans une
rédaction qui était d'ailleurs assez
proche d'une rédaction proposée par
notre collègue jean jacques hyest
l'article tel qu'il a été amendé par le
sénat est le fruit d'un très gros
travail qui a été fait avec jean louis
carrère je tiens à le souligner qui a
donné lieu aussi à dialogue avec vous
monsieur le ministre jean yves le drian
je tiens aussi à le souligner je veux
dire avec beaucoup de force
que dans cet article 13 tel qu'il a été
voté par le sénat puis adopté par la
commission de la défense de l'assemblée
nationale puis par la commission des
lois de l'assemblée nationale puis par
l'assemblée nationale elle même il n'y a
que des dispositions qui en matière de
renseignement 10 oui nous devons avoir
les moyens de lutter contre le
terrorisme mais cela doit être fait dans
des conditions de garantie et de
contrôle qui respecte les libertés
individuelles la vie privée et les
données personnelles
voilà pourquoi il n'y a dans cet article
et je mets au défi quiconque pense le
contraire de donner des arguments
premièrement s'agissant des fadettes
il y a un choix qui a été fait par le
parlement que cela donne lieu à une
autorisation du premier ministre et non
plus du ministre de l'intérieur
situation actuelle
s'agissant de la géolocalisation
deuxième point pour avoir accès à la
géolocalisation ce qui est très
nécessaire par rapport au terrorisme en
particulier il faudra que l'un des trois
ministres compétents chargés de la
défense monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur où des douanes fasse une
demande écrite et motivée au premier
ministre et lui ou la personne qui
parlera en son nom devra faire une
réponse écrite c'est une garantie qui
aujourd'hui n'existe pas que nous créons
je précise que sur ces deux points
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui il existe des dizaines de
milliers d'interceptions qui ne sont pas
régis par ces dispositions en troisième
lieu nous augmentons
considérablement le rôle de la cncis
commission nationale de contrôle des
interceptions de sécurité
nous lui donnons des pouvoirs de
contrôle mais aussi d'intervention dans
le cours
du processus
et aussi des possibilités bien entendu
de faire connaître ses positions de
manière qu'il en soit du compte
quatrièmement pour ce qui est de la cnil
la cnil a été entendu par le rapporteur
que je suis et aussi par le rapporteur
qui est le président de la commission de
la défense jean louis carrère sur cette
mesure
d'autre part la cnil sera forcément
amené à s'exprimer sur le décret qui
sera nécessaire pour que ce texte ne
s'applique
et monsieur le ministre l'a dit tout à
l'heure
enfin je tiens à préciser que nous
sommes accusés d' élargir les le champ
d'intervention dans ces domaines par
exemple à un certain nombre de réalités
e économique scientifique sécurité en
ces domaines maintien de groupements
dissous reconstitution etc tout cela
figure et j'ai ici le texte et chacun
peut s'y référer dans la loi eux du de
1991 et ceux qui figurent dans cette loi
de 1991 est devenu l'article l 241 2 du
code de la sécurité intérieure c'est la
loi du 10 juillet 91 alors certains se
réveillent en disant mais vous
choisissez ses champs mais nous
reprenons intégralement ce qui a été
voté il y à 23 ans
cinquièmement au lieu de
rafistoler la loi de 2006 qui vous le
savez sur un caduque au 31 décembre 2015
nous avons ré inscrire tout le processus
dans la loi de 91 alors je dis tout ça
mes chers collègues parce que lorsque
nous avons voté cela il y a eu de
nombreux commentaires positifs
et puis trois semaines et demie après
est apparu un communiqué de l'asic
c'est une association qui regroupe les
majors du web qui a dit ce qui a été
voté peu peut-être poser des problèmes
ou pose d'ailleurs des problèmes en
matière de libertés publiques
et puis à partir de là il y à une sorte
d'emballement et toute une sorte toute
une série de déclarations ont été faites
sur les réseaux sociaux c'est d'ailleurs
très symptomatique de la façon dont
fonctionne notre société eh bien je
tiens à dire que quand même ceux qui
nous font aujourd'hui ces reproches qui
donc ne nous accusent à propos d'un
texte qui n'est peut-être qui peut être
perfectible évidemment il y aura bien
d'autres débats sur ces questions euh de
l'internet sur ces questions de la
sécurité dans ces domaines et cetera il
y aura bien sûr d'autres débats mais qui
nous accusent à propos d'un texte qui ne
comprend que des garanties nouvelles de
porter atteinte ou de risquer de porter
atteinte aux libertés la vie privée aux
données personnelles nous leur disons
que peut-être il serait bien qu'il
balaie un peu devant leur porte car
enfin ces majors du web ont d'abord nié
avoir fourni des informations à la haine
s à et au programme prisme et puis on
finit par déclarer qu'en effet il y
avait de très nombreuses informations et
il y avait de l'économie fait avec des
milliards de données personnelles donc
nous avançons nous voulons que nos
services de renseignement soit efficace
nous voulons pouvoir aller rechercher
les otages et lutter contre le
terrorisme mais nous le faisons dans des
conditions où nous avons tous la volonté
des garanties et du contrôle absolument
nécessaire je tenais mes chers collègues
à faire avec force cette mise au point
je vous remercie vous remercie monsieur
le rapporteur pour avis
du ministre souhaitez vous la parole
la présidente je ne vais pas mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
reprendre l'ensemble de la problématique
de cette loi de programmation militaire
je me suis déjà exprimé à de nombreuses
reprises sur quasiment tous les sujets
qui ont été évoqués dans les différentes
interventions que que je viens
d'entendre je voudrais simplement
apporter quelques éléments
complémentaires ponctuelles sur des
points précis qui ont été soulevées par
là où l'autre en m'excusant ne paraît
bon à tous parce que sur un certain
nombre d'observations faites par les uns
et les autres j'ai eu l'occasion déjà
dans d'autres en première lecture ou
dans mon propos initial de donner ma
position
d'abord je voudrais dire que
sur la bosse jean pierre chevènement est
parti c'est lui qui a parlé de la bosse
j'ai moins d'ancienneté dans la vie
parlementaire que jean pierre
chevènement mais pas beaucoup moins et
quand je suis devenu député en 1978 la
commission de la défense de l'assemblée
nationale
il y avait déjà la bosse et j'avais
appris à ce moment là qu'il fallait
pousser la bosse et me retrouvant là
maintenant elle est toujours là et il
faut toujours la poussée de dire que ce
cette situation n'est pas n'est pas
nouvelle ceci dit elle est préoccupante
et je suis assez d'accord avec les
observations des uns et des autres y
compris monsieur côté sur la sur le fait
que le report de charge devient
insupportable il n'est pas aussi
insupportable que se disait monsieur
monsieur larcher puisqu'il donnait des
chiffres de 4 milliards ne nous ne
sommes pas à 4 milliards nous sommes à 3
milliards cent en raison des 500
millions que j'ai obtenus pour compenser
le report de charges qui a été initiée
du fait de la manière de régler la loi
de finances de 2013 nous sommes autour
de 3 milliards c'est beaucoup trop c'est
pas au delà mais c'est néanmoins
néanmoins beaucoup trop il faudra
essayer de dans l'avenir dudit remédier
mais les 500 millions d'euros dont il a
été fait auquel il a été fait allusion
total tout à plusieurs reprises tout à
l'heure ont été obtenus pour éviter que
ce report de charge ne soit trop lourd
et qui me permettent
de passer dès la fin de l'année 2013 et
au début 2014 les commandes prévues et
j'ai annoncé tout à l'heure dans mon
propos initial la liste des commandes
que j'avais pu passer que je passais la
en sort en ce moment qui sont
extrêmement importantes et qui
permettent d'assurer la
fiabilité complètent la programmation
telle qu'elle est proposée à votre à
votre vote je voudrais dire aussi
concernant à monsieur renner qui a fait
une suggestion concernant
l'a400m et la collaboration avec les
britanniques sur l'a400m qui me permet
d'ailleurs de revenir sur une autre
observation concerne la collaboration
avec des briques il ya un sommet
franco-britannique en fin janvier et
c'est la question de la coopération de
défense sera à l'ordre du jour y compris
de notre côté l'hypothèse d'une
collaboration sur le soutien en matière
d' à 400m sommes nous avons reçu le
premier le premier la première machine
les le royaume uni sont préparés s'est
réceptionné son premier
appareil et nous sommes en train de
discuter avec eux sur la possibilité de
faire en sorte d éléments de base de
mutualisation ce serait un pas important
dans la collaboration entre la france et
la grande bretagne je voulais le
signaler à monsieur renner parce qu'il y
avait fait allusion monsieur chevènement
sur un point je ne réponds que sur les
points très précis monsieur chevènement
avait demandé des précisions sur les
drones d'observation et l'évolution
concernant cette la possibilité pour
l'europe de se doter d'un outil et de
machines spécifiques sans avoir besoin
d'aller
acheter ce ratage est essentiellement
aux états unis comme nous l'avons fait
par absence de
capacité au niveau européen je voudrais
vous dire ici que si tout va bien
au moment du
conseil européen qui sera chargée de d2
d'étudier les questions de défense le 18
et le 19 juin dix neuf ou 10 à 20 18 19
décembre la question d'un
projet de drone de nouvelle génération
effectué en commun entre disney
l'ensemble des pays européens sera à
l'ordre du jour et j'espère validé par
les chefs d'état et de gouvernements ce
qui serait une très grande avancée qui
s'ajoutera à au club des utilisateurs de
rippert qui vont être qui va être lancé
dès ce dès ce conseil européen de
défense aussi donc j'espère avoir donné
des éléments de satisfaction à jean
pierre chevènement par rapport à son
observation j'ai bien noté
toujours les mêmes interrogations les
mêmes inquiétudes de plusieurs
intervenants concernant les ressources
exceptionnelles je me suis je vous ai
dit à plusieurs reprises que j'estimais
qu'avec 3 5 % de ressources
exceptionnels sur l'ensemble des 180
maintenant qu'elles sont 80 10 milliards
6 que des enveloppes jusqu'à la fin 2019
nous étions dans un cadre qui n'était
quand même pas
exceptionnel le dire mais que
l'indication qui était donné dans
l'index de la halle de la loi de
programmation sur eux mêmes dans le
texte désormais sur les possibilités les
routes nergie sur lesquels ses
ressources exceptionnelles seraient
mobilisés et est déjà une avancée et le
fait que le sénat ait mis des cliquer
partout des clauses de sauvegarde à tout
instant à mon avis devrait vous rassurer
sur le fait que les ressources
essentielles seront au rendez vous en
tout cas moi j'en suis intimement
convaincu et les 500 millions que j'ai
pu obtenir pour la fin de gestion 2013
sont déjà le signe de la volonté de
gouvernement de d'assurer ses
orientations je voudrais aussi dire à
monsieur bockel que sur la brigade
franco allemande
nous avons j'ai pris la décision de
dissoudre le régiment de donaueschingen
pour un certain nombre de raisons en
particulier parce qu'il était très
onéreux et que sa décision
d'implantation n'était peut-être pas
automatiquement la plus évidente mais
par contre nous allons
affecté à la brigade franco allemande le
1er régiment d'infanterie de sarrebourg
qui est à des régiments les plus
historiques de france qui en plus un
régiment plus important que le 110e
régiment d'infanterie de donaueschingen
et qui est en plus
plus plus non seulement plus historique
mais plus équipés puisqu'il et dispose
de deux félins et qu' il apportera une
contribution significative à la brigade
franco-allemande qui sera à ce moment là
plus équilibrée d'ailleurs dans ces
répartition entre la france et
l'allemagne reste le sujet de la
mobilisation de la bf a sur un certain
nombre d'objectifs et on en est toujours
au même point que il faudra mon collègue
allemand est tout à fait sûr celle
d'amener il faut qu'on réfléchisse
ensemble à la possibilité de mobiliser
tout ou partie de la brigade franco
allemande sur un théâtre
d'opportunités rapide qui pourrait
peut-être demain le mali en tout cas
c'est un dans cette direction là que
nous travaillons voilà pour l'essentiel
des propos que je voulais vous tenez je
veux dire monsieur trillard que s'il y
est c'est n'est pas perçue en 2013 pour
certains qui sera placée qu'en 2014
c'est parce que le loup voix marche pas
bien et que c'est un dérapage du loup
voit que je subis tous les mois tous les
mois tous les mois ces perturbations
auxquelles décidé de porter remède et
vous savez les conséquences que les
distorsions de nous voir sur le système
2 seuls peuvent avoir sur le moral des
forces quand je ne quand je vais dans
les unités la référence au moral elle
porte essentiellement sur le voit
essentiellement sur le voit et c'est
vraiment le point le point difficile
aujourd'hui auxquels nous essayons de
remédier et j'ai pris à cet égard des
décisions qui s'imposaient et enfin je
vais pas redire à monsieur gautier
combien je suis préoccupé du concept de
groupement tactique j'ai fait allusion
tout à l'heure c'est un sujet de
réflexion pour moi même et aussi je
l'espère pour les acteurs européens afin
qu'il ne soit plus uniquement inscrit
dans les textes mais qu'ont-ils n'y
ajoute les modalités de mobilisation qui
font défaut qui ont fait défaut encore
là dans la situation que nous avons
rencontrés on réplique centrafricaine
voilà les quelques remarques je voulais
faire en complément de tout ce que j'ai
dit dans mon propos introductif et pour
répondre une nouvelle fois aux orateurs
en vous remerciant encore une nouvelle
fois de vos contributions
cette et l'élaboration de cette loi et
en souhaitant que puisse être adopté ce
soir
si monsieur le ministre la discussion
générale est close je pense et je vous
propose monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président la commission que nous pouvons
envisager de prolonger le débat pour la
séance pour la discussion du texte de la
commission pour un temps néanmoins
raisonnable elle vous êtes d'accord très
bien donc nous passons à la discussion
du texte de la commission
j'ai une demande de parole sur l'article
2 de notre collègue leila aichi vous
avez la parole chers collègues
madame le président messieurs ministre
messieurs les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues puisque nous débattons
aujourd'hui notre modèle d'armée pour
les cinq prochaines années je souhaitais
profité des travaux réalisés à
l'assemblée nationale sur le changement
climatique afin d'aller plus loin tant
d'un point de vue militaire que
diplomatique alors que le rapport annexé
entend s'inscrire dans une vision
prospective
la france peine à se positionner sur
l'émergence de nouveaux risques au
premier rang desquels figure le
dérèglement climatique
c'est en effet un facteur d'instabilité
à part entière ayant des conséquences
stratégiques majeures sur la sécurité
des états et du système international en
effet nul n'ignore que le dérèglement
climatique accroît les stress hydrique
nourricier démographique et redistribue
les cartes de l'accès aux ressources il
devient une source de tension dans des
zones déjà instable le soudan le nigeria
la somalie la mer de chine méridoniale
le moyen-orient et bien d'autres à
l'occasion du sommet de l'elysée le
président de la république a lui-même
reconnu qu'il y avait je cite urgence
pour l'environnement et aussi pour la
sécurité car quand il ya des désordres
climatiques c'est aussi un facteur qui
permet à des groupes d'utiliser la
pauvreté la misère le désarroi pour
essayer de faire prévaloir leurs
intérêts c'est justement reconnaissant
la prééminence de ce lien entre la
dégradation socio environnemental et
conflits que la green différence promeut
une redéfinition de la vision militaire
classique elle prend le parti d'une
approche préventive des conflits et par
là cherchent à donner à l'europe de la
défense une opportunité de prendre cher
de fait de sa dimension globale le
dérèglement climatique se doit d'être
intégrés aux diagnostics stratégiques de
la france la pensée française reste
dictée par une vision traditionnelle de
la gestion des risques car si une
approche globale existe elle reste
cantonnée à la gestion post conflit
notre réflexion s'appuie sur un constat
simple la nature des risques et des
menaces qui pèsent aujourd'hui sur
l'europe et sur la france a
fondamentalement changé ce que le livre
blanc appelle menace de la faiblesse
incarné par la faillite de l'état malien
ou centrafricain est un autre sens la
menace principale celle qui doit
structurer notre outil de défense ce
sont ces crises qui du fait du
dérèglement climatique accapareront
demain les efforts de nos armées et de
nos diplomates en effet une vision
préventive des conflits passe également
par une diplomatie adapté lors de la
table ronde sur le braconnage organisait
la semaine dernière le président a
rappelé la volonté de la france de
prendre part à la lutte contre cette
pratique est contre le trafic illégal de
biodiversité un premier pas significatif
sera ainsi d'inclure une clause sur la
protection de l'environnement dans les
conventions de défense ratifiée par la
france en effet le trafic illégal
d'espèces protégées et le troisième au
monde et représente près de 20 milliards
de dollars chaque année alors qu'elle
alimente directement des réseaux mafieux
et terroristes la lutte contre ces
activités criminelles constitue un des
éléments clés de la prévention des
conflits notamment sur le continent
africain les etats-unis ont dès la
décennie 2000 élevé les mutations
climatiques et leurs conséquences sur
les sociétés au rang d' enjeu d'enjeux
stratégiques
il s'agit pour la france de ne pas
accuser de retard si une réflexion sur
la sécurité environnementale a été
amorcée au niveau de l'état major
français et je m'en réjouis l'effort ne
doit pas s'arrêter posons nous la
question de l'efficacité de la
dissuasion face un stress hydrique ou
nourricier interrogeons nous sur la
capacité pour un quelconque pays de
sécuriser ses approvisionnements sans
d'abord assurer la paix mondiale qui
soutient son économie ainsi nous paraît
primordial pour la france de dresser une
feuille de route précise pour les
prochaines années alors monsieur le
ministre j'ai deux questions à vous
soumettre premièrement faisant écho aux
récentes déclarations du président de la
république il semble nécessaire de
reconnaître le dérèglement climatique
comme un risque stratégique à part
entière ainsi quelle en sera la
traduction concrète pour notre modèle
d'armé dans les années à venir et
deuxième question d'un point de vue
diplomatique au minitère quelles
solutions proposez-vous pour intégrer
une clause sur la protection de
l'environnement dans l'ensemble de nos
futurs traités bilatéraux de défense je
vous remercie
merci chers collègues j'ai deux
amendements présentés par le groupe
écologiste ils ne sont pas en discussion
que oui monsieur le président
oui vous en prie vous avez le droit de
parole si vous me permettez sans vouloir
trop rallonger le débat permettez-moi
tout juste un mot pour appuyer la
démarche de leila aichi d'abord je salue
madame la sénatrice la constance de
votre engagement
depuis que nous avons le plaisir de vous
voir siéger à nos côtés ancien de la
commission vous n'avez cessé de
travailler de façon très constructive et
novatrice à éveiller nos consciences
notamment la mienne au delà des seuls
enjeux environnementaux
on pense à l'éco-conception des
matériels militaires par exemple déjà
prévues par la loi de programmation vous
nous inviter à aller plus loin et
aborder plus globalement les
bouleversements géopolitiques
qui naissent aujourd'hui n'est plus
encore qui naîtront deux mains des
changements climatiques votre
intervention de cet après-midi
témoignent de cet engagement je souscris
à votre approche nous devons avoir
l'audace d'une vision prospective et
prendre en compte l'émergence de
nouveaux risques aux conséquences
multi dimensionnelle ce sont en effet
des facteurs d'instabilité à part
entière
quand vous parlez de stress hydrique de
déséquilibre alimentaire de dynamique
démographique on pourrait rajouter des
logiques d'accaparement
des grands émergents notamment comme
l'indiqué tout à l'heure madame de
messine d'ailleurs des terres des
ressources ou même d'accès à l'eau
potable
nous reconnaissons la d'indéniables
facteur de tension souvent d'ailleurs à
l'échelle régionale le livre blanc
reconnaît d'ailleurs les conséquences
stratégiques de la fonte des glaces
notamment dans l'arctique un amendement
de l'assemblée nationale à l'article 2
de la loi de programmation que nous
sommes en train d'examiner est venue
conforter et amplifier cette approche
sans doute avez vous raison et nous
faut-il aller plus loin c'est d'ailleurs
ce qu'a fait le président de la
république en incluant un important
volet changement climatique au récent
sommet avec les chefs d'état africains
je souhaite donc que nous ayons un
dialogue nourri avec le gouvernement à
ce sujet sans doute dans la perspective
de la conférence climat
je vous remercie monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre
moi j'ai pas
prolonger trop longuement les pros ce
que vient de dire le président de la
commission de l'aide de la défense et
des affaires étrangères je partage votre
interpellation et vous avez raison
d'appeler à ce moment notre attention
sur les risques que représentent les
enjeux climatiques dans les conflits du
futur à la fois risquent de la faiblesse
c et menace de la force ça vaut pour les
deux par rapport au référentiel du livre
blanc et le président carrère a rappelé
qu' un amendement avait été prise en
compte à l'assemblée nationale pour
tirer toutes les conséquences fac alerté
sur les conséquences de ces de ces
menaces nouvelles je suis très ouvert à
un dialogue sur ce sujet parce que la
commission présidée par jean charest
pour être le bon lebon creuset pour
qu'on puisse élaborer des éléments
complémentaires dans le sens que vous
indiquez et vous remercie monsieur le
ministre je suis donc saisi de deux
amendements du groupe écologiste qui ne
sont pas en discussion commune mais si
vous vouliez des présentes et en même
temps ça serait bien de vous remercie
voilà un beau show madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président carrère mes chers collègues je
voulais tout d'abord saluer la
courtoisie la sérénité des débats de cet
après midi et surtout dire toute notre
satisfaction d'avoir pu entendre à la
fois les propos du président carrère et
du ministre concernant l'interpellation
tout à fait pertinente de notre collègue
les lie chi qui est habituellement chef
de file sur les questions de défense
les deux amendements que vous avez
évoqué madame la présidente vise à
reprendre en fait notre interpellation
concernant
l'absence de réflexion suffisante selon
nous à propos de la dissuasion nucléaire
est donc le premier amendement visait à
proposer de remettre un rapport avant le
31 décembre 2019 sur le coût du
démantèlement des composante sous-marine
et aéroportée de la dissuasion nucléaire
nous sommes tout à fait conscients du
fait que ce coût est colossal peu être
ce coût est il aussi un obstacle à
mettre en place la politique que nous
appelons de nos souhaits pour autant la
peur n'évite pas le danger et nous
aimerions avoir un éclairage précis sur
ce dossier deuxième amendement donc
l'amendement numéro 8 rectifié suite à
l'article de la ce cet amendement
révocation à rouvrir le débat sur la
place de la dissuasion nucléaire dans
notre stratégie de défense simplement un
débat qui ne serait pas un débat entre
experts de grande qualité au sein de la
commission défense mais un débat qui
serait partagé en séance en session pour
tous les membres de la haute assemblée
ça nous paraît extrêmement important
donc même si nous nous nourrissons
qu'assez peu d'espoir quant à la
destinée de ces deux amendements nous
aimerions qu'ils permettent un saut
qualitatif dans le débat il y as
pluralité de penser sur ce sujet et nous
pensons que la biodiversité y compris
sur les questions de défense est une
richesse pour le pays et n'est en aucun
cas un handicap ou une faiblesse je vous
remercie de votre écoute je vous
remercie madame blue l'avis de la
commission monsieur le président sur ces
deux amendements sur les deux
amendements les avis sont défavorables
et la commission s'est prononcé à une
très large majorité sur ce point là
néanmoins je voudrais dire 1 1 madame
bouche ou que sur les deux aspects nous
allons essayer d'aller dans le sens
qu'elle souhaite c'est à dire que nous
allons essayer de trouver les modalités
d'avoir les prix qui seraient les prix
réels liés à un démantèlement quant au
second moi je ne vais pas me substituer
à monsieur le ministre de la défense ni
à ma collègue de l'assemblée nationale
vous connaissez ma position par rapport
à la dissuasion nucléaire elle est aussi
claire que celle de notre ministre mais
en même temps je souscris tout à fait à
la possibilité d'avoir un débat serait
mais est très très très nourris au sein
de notre assemblée
merci monsieur le président la
commission monsieur le ministre votre
avis je me suis déjà exprimé madame la
présidente
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs sur
ce sujet là plusieurs reprises en
conséquence de quoi j'ai le même avis
que le président de la commission de la
défense des affaires étrangères je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre y at il
des demandes d'explications de vote sur
ces sur sur le premier amendement le set
rectifié je ne vois pas je vais donc le
mettre aux voix qui est pour voter cet
amendement
merci qui est contre
merci abstentions il n'est pas adoptée
même vote pour lui vite rectifier mes
chers collègues même vote je vous
remercie je vais mettre aux voix
l'article 2 qui est pour voter l'article
2 et pour
merci qui est contre
merci abstentions l'article 2 est
adoptée
sur l'article 3 je ne suis saisi d'aucun
amendement ni d'aucune demande de parole
je mets aux voix cet article
même vote très bien donc il est adopté
sur les articles 3 bis à 4 qu'inquiets
serait sans discussion je ne suis saisi
également d' aucun amendement ni
d'aucune demande de parole puis-je
considérer que le vote est le même une
même vote
merci
oui il ya une demande de parole a le
même vote d'accor je vous remercie même
votre
je n'ai pas cogité pas compris avaient
tous ces parfaits donc la version
adoptée nous sommes à l'article 4 sexy
est ce un amendement 9,9 rectifié bis
c'est toujours madame beauchamp qui
présente
maintenant la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues en fait
c'est dans la même lignée du débat
précédant ce donc nous souhaitons qu'il
y ait un rapport spécifiquement sur les
coûts de l'ensemble des programmes
afférents à chaque composant de la
dissuasion nucléaire si vous ne nous
voulons avoir un débat sera imposée sur
la doctrine peut-être que cette
importante je vous remercie merci chers
collègues la vie la commission monsieur
le président c'est un avis défavorable
je pense que satisfaction pour être
donnée à madame beauchamp si on part du
principe d'avoir un grand débat large
sur les questions de vision nucléaire
donc avis défavorable de la commission
je vous remercie monsieur le président
monsieur mini ce même avis je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre y at il
des demandes d'explications de vote sur
cet amendement je ne vois pas je le mets
au voit donc deux avis défavorables qui
est pour
merci qui est contre
merci mes chers collègues abstentions la
maman n'est pas adopté je vais mettre
voir l'article 4 sexy est ce qui est
pour
votre sur l'article
je vous remercie que les contres
abstentions
l'article 4 pièces est adoptée sur
l'article et 4,70 je ne suis saisi
d'aucun amendement n'est d'aucune
demande de parole je mets aux voix cet
article qui est pour
mais je préfère demander monsieur le
président qui est contre
abstention je vous remercie il est
adopté sur les articles 5 à 11 les
restantes en discussion je ne suis saisi
doc également d' aucun amendement ni
aucune demande de parole puis je
considérais que le vote est le même que
les articles précédents c'est le même
vote je vous remercie donc ces articles
sont appelés à l'article 13 je suis
saisi d'une demande de ce nom puisque
monsieur sûr c'est d'exprimer un
amendement aux actifs et air malin bush
où il présente
madame la présidente monsieur michaud
monsieur le président la commission mes
chers collègues on ne pourra pas nous
soupçonner d'intervenir pour le rôle des
majeurs tout à l'heure qui a été dénoncé
par le président sueur et le revirement
d'une position que certains ne
s'expliquait pas nous avons été plutôt
interpellé par un certain nombre de
citoyens et notamment de geeks qui nous
ont alertés sur le fait qu' on n'était
pas vraiment obligés de passer devant un
juge deuxième réserve il n'y avait pas
vraiment de demande d'autorisation
préalable et dernier point je n'ai pas
été rassurés complètement sur ce point
la cnil a peut-être été auditionné je ne
suis pas sûr que la cnil a été saisie
pour avis dans l'est format coutume est
telle que c'est privé actuellement et
donc pour toutes ces raisons
nous avons été troublés qantas est à cet
article 13 et même si nous ne
méconnaissons pas la nécessité de lutter
contre le terrorisme et d'être énergique
sur ce point nous vous proposons la
suppression de cet article en attendant
de remettre les choses à plat je vous
remercie chers collègues l'avis de la
commission monsieur le président bon
écoute et
puisqu'il semblerait que mon collègue et
ami jean pierre sueur n'a pas été
convaincant je vais essayer de faire
assaut de pédagogie
et on verra si j'y parviens
cet amendement madame vise à supprimer
l'article 13 dont on parle beaucoup en
ce moment souvent à tort et à travers de
surcroît vous le savez depuis le début
notre volonté déterminée à une grande
majorité ici est d'arriver à un vote
conforme pas en bâclant le débat mais
pour que tout simplement il y est un
budget pour notre défense à compter du
1er janvier donc ceci n'est pas un
argument qui rentrent mais c'est quand
même un petit peu un élément de contexte
initialement cet article 13 visait
uniquement à clarifier le régime de la
géolocalisation en temps réel qui
consiste à localiser un objet téléphone
ou ordinateur portable par exemple en
temps réel ou de manière différée il
visait à répondre à une fragilité
juridique
résultant d'un arrêt de la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme du 2
septembre 2010 dans lequel la cour de
strasbourg rappelé la nécessité de
disposer pour cette méthode d'une loi
ouvrez les guillemets particulièrement
précises fermez les guillemets en
première lecture le sénat avait adopté
un amendement présenté par le président
de la commission des lois jean pierre
sueur ayant fait ayant un objet beaucoup
plus large puisqu'il vise à refondre le
régime juridique de données de l'accès
aux données de collection issue de
l'article 6 de la loi du 23 janvier 2006
les fameuses fadettes
en le rapprochant du régime plus
protecteur des libertés publiques des
interceptions de communications issues
de la loi du 10 juillet 91 donc le
rapprocher d'un texte de loi beaucoup
plus protecteur des libertés publiques
ce rapprochement répond à une
préoccupation exprimée par la commission
nationale de contrôle des interceptions
de sécurité
la scène cs par la délégation
parlementaire au renseignement et par
les commissions des lois des deux
assemblées en effet le régime actuel de
l'accès aux données de connexion
applicable uniquement en matière de
prévention du terrorisme est un régime
transitoire qui doit être réformée avant
la fin 2015 vous le savez le dispositif
adopté par le ca senna est à la fois
plus adapté aux besoins opérationnels
des services car il sera ouvert à tous
les services de renseignements et pour
des motifs plus large que la seule
prévention du terrorisme mais aussi plus
protecteur des libertés publiques
écoutez bien les demandes de motiver
d'accès aux données de connexion seront
soumises à la décision d'une personne
qualifiée auprès du premier ministre et
du premier ministre lui-même et non
auprès du ministre de l'intérieur comme
aujourd'hui alors ce n'est pas que leur
soient plus dignes de confiance que
l'autre mais quand on sacralise jusqu'à
l'autorisation du premier ministre on va
encore au delà vous le comprenez bien
chaque demande fera l'objet d'un
contrôle effectué par la commission
nationale de contrôle des interceptions
de sécurité
autorité administrative indépendante qui
est présidée par un magistrat et qui
comprend des parlementaires
les conditions d'utilisation de la
géolocalisation en temps réel seront
quant à elles
plus strictes que celles prévues
initialement par le projet de loi
puisqu'elles seront identiques à celles
prévues pour les interceptions de
sécurité
l'autorisation sera accordée sur demande
et crit est motivé du ministre concerné
par décision écrite du premier ministre
est communiqué au président de la cncis
les auteurs de l'amendement soutiennent
que la cnil n'a pas été saisi de cet
article si elle a été consulté par le
gouvernement sur plusieurs articles du
projet de loi il est vrai que l'ags
lille n'a pas été consultée sur la
nouvelle rédaction de cet article
puisque cette nouvelle rédaction résulte
d'un amendement parlementaire et donc on
ne peut pas nous faire ce reproche pour
autant mon collègue jean pierre sueur et
moi même à des heures et en des lieux
différents nous avons chacun conditionné
pendant plus d'une heure les
représentants de la cnil qui ont pu
faire valoir leur point de vue un autre
il est prévu et ça ça devrait vous
rassurer que les modalités d'application
de cet article seront fixées par décret
en conseil d'état pris après avis de la
cnil et de la commission nationale de
contrôle des interceptions de sécurité
et que ce décret précisera notamment la
procédure de suivi des demandes et les
conditions et durée de conservation des
informations ou documents enfin à
l'assemblée nationale tant la commission
des lois que la commission de la défense
ont approuvé la rédaction de cet article
le seul changement des députés a porté
sur la durée de l'autorisation de la
géolocalisation en temps réel alors que
le sénat avait obtenu un délai maximal
de bi jours la commission des lois de
l'assemblée nationale a souhaité porter
la durée des autorisations à quatre mois
mais nos interventions ont permis que la
commission de la défense reviennent un
délai de 30 jours ce qui nous paraissait
plus compatible avec l'esprit même de la
loi au sein de notre commission nous
avons considéré qu'un délai de 30 jours
présentait un équilibre raisonnable pour
concilier l'impératif d'efficacité et la
protection des droits et des libertés
individuelles je vous promets mesdames
que nous avons été
fondée marc animé par le respect des
libertés individuelles
si le président la commission c'est donc
un avis défavorable
d'accord merci monsieur ministre
l'avis du gouvernement est aussi
défavorable je voudrais reprendre
quelques éléments qui ont été évoqués et
pas madame bouchon est en opposition
par le présent carrère que je soutiens
dans son argumentation et je vais faire
observer que je me suis déjà exprimé sur
le sujet dans l'ordre de mon exposé
initial je vous rappelle que c'était pas
dans l'intention du gouvernement de
traiter l'ensemble de ce sujet au moment
de la lpm l'avion simplement qu'une
préoccupation c'était de traiter du cas
particulier la géolocalisation en temps
réel mais il a été rappelé par le
président carrère et que le sénat avait
souhaité dans sa sagesse
respectable et coutumières
de avait souhaité sur l'initiative à la
fois du président sueur et du sénateur y
est de revisiter plus globalement
l'origine de l'accès de l'ensemble des
services spécialisés de renseignements
aux données et documents de connexion
détenus par les opérateurs de
communications électroniques et le texte
de l'article 13 ça a été dit tout à
l'heure c'est un texte de production aux
sénatoriales que le gouvernement a
soutenu et ce texte a été voté à
l'unanimité au sénat je trouve que c'est
une bonne contribution et c'est un texte
équilibré alors je voudrais rappeler
plusieurs choses que ça semble faire
débat et je trouve ce débat étonnamment
tardif
sur un sujet qui est initié depuis déjà
un certain temps quelques l accélération
qui
assez particulière enfin on en essayant
d'en tirer les réflexions nécessaires
après en tout cas il n'est pas
totalement lié ce débat à la question
militaire mais je voudrais donc redire
que l'article 13 part d'un dispositif
d'accès administratif aux données de
connexion qui existe dans le droit
positif depuis 2006 et que le conseil
constitutionnel a validé en son temps au
nom de la porte du renseignement la
préservation des intérêts font un
manteau de la nation et si cet article
étant effectivement le régime existant
pour l'adapter aux missions et à
l'arrivée de nos services de
renseignement
en collant d'ailleurs au périmètre
d'autorisation des interceptions de
sécurité organisée par loi de 1991 il en
renforce surtout le contrôle et c'est ce
qu'a dit le président sueur tout à
l'heure par rapport à la situation
actuelle contrôler la fois politique
démocratique et technique notamment du
fait de l'intervention du premier
ministre pour la géolocalisation en
temps réel et du fait des pouvoirs
accrus de la cncs qui est une autorité
administrative indépendante
je souligne aussi que la ceni elle sera
appelée à se prononcer le présent car
elle vient de le dire mais je donne la
position du gouvernement sera appelé à
se prononcer sur le décret d'application
de l'article 13 et notamment sur la mode
les modalités la durée de conservation
des données enfin ce dispositif pourra
le cas échéant au bout d'un premier
temps de fonctionnement est de
réexaminer à l'occasion des rendez-vous
législatives à venir en matière de
renseignement puisqu'il y aura un texte
concernant le renseignement au cours de
la mandature et j'espère assez
rapidement du fait des durées limitées
des dispositions relatives à l'accès aux
fichiers administratives et au passage
arnhem de rich or die évoqué tout cela
aussi dans mon intervention de départ
enfin s'agissant du respect des libertés
publiques individuelles le gouvernement
on est soucieux comme le montre le
projet annoncé lors du séminaire
numérique du 28 février 2013 de
présenter un texte de loi sur les
libertés les droits et libertés
numériques ce sera en 2014 et c'est une
tâche que qu'accomplira ma collègue
fleur pellerin j'estime pour ma part que
nous avons là un bon équilibre qu'il
importe de le préserver faire en sorte
que le respect des libertés publiques
auquel nous sommes très attachés soit
préservée qu'en même temps nous ayons
l'efficacité opérationnelle pour
sauvegarder par ailleurs mais d'une
autre manière les mêmes libertés messimy
sionisme monsieur le président voulait
rajouter rassurez vous c'est pour
demander à madame la sénatrice de de
bien vouloir leur retirer cet amendement
que moi moi je trouve que ça n'a pas de
sens de le faire battre parce que pour
moi cet amendement comme celui des
explications que nous avons fournis
neuvième plus
président mais la bouche vous êtes
sollicité pour un retrait madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre monsieur
le président de la commission
nous sommes extrêmement sensibles et
honoré de la précision des réponses
néanmoins l'inquiétude n'est pas
totalement levé donc nous ne sommes sans
sens sans doute quant à l'issue de ce
vote mais néanmoins nous pensons que en
démocratie on peut aussi poser des
questions qui dérangent même si nous
sommes prêts à revoir notre position
quand nous serons rassurés simplement
dire que pour notre génération nous
sommes
pas en politique depuis très longtemps
nous quand on était tout petit a eu des
affaires des coûts qui a eu des choses
comme ça avec des gouvernements de
couleurs très différentes et donc
peut-être que ça résonne de façon un
petit peu troublante en nous et donc
nous maintenons cet amendement pour une
question juste de démocratie et de
principe mais nous remercions la qualité
des réponses et nous y réfléchirons pour
la suite
si madame blue madame vous voulez vous
avez demandé la parole pour une
explication
parce que le jeu va rallonger les débats
président monsieur le ministre je
présente la commission juste pour dire
que je ne voterai pas cet amendement de
suppression pour plusieurs raisons non
pas que nous soyons pas attachés au
respect de la vie privée surtout à
l'heure de l'internet puisque nous avons
dans cette maison commis plusieurs
rapports notamment sous l'égide
anne-marie escoffier et d'yves détraigne
sur sur le sujet donc le sénat a
toujours été très préoccupés par cette
question de respect de la vie privée il
se trouve que la loi de programmation
militaire est le premier texte qui va
donner un accès à des documents
personnels et à des données personnelles
alliances & soul que c'est sous l'angle
de la loi de programmation militaire et
c'est tout à fait normal qu'un certain
nombre de gens puissent puisse émouvoir
néanmoins je voudrais quand même indiqué
que ni jean pierre sueur ni le président
carrère nom des réputations de
liberticide ni dans cette maison ni
ailleurs oui et que donc moi je leur
fais absolument confiance que le
parcours notamment du président sueur de
ce point de vue là est absolument sans
tache et que si le ministre et le
président et le président de la
commission des lois nous ont indiqué que
les commissions nécessaire la cnil et
les autres commission était saisie
du problème et avait donné un avis
favorable et que pour les décrets et que
pour la suite de l'application de cet
article les principales instances
concernées par le respect de la vie
privée au moment d'internet serait
également concerné je vois absolument
pas de raison de mettre en doute
l'ensemble de ces dispositions et c'est
pourquoi je ne voterai pas à
l'amendement de suppression si madame
boulet y at il d'autres demandes de
parole je n'en vois pas je vais donc m
il n'y a que des convaincus son assiette
nous allons voir je vais donc métro à
l'amendement 11 ratifie était
représentée par madame bouchon qui a
reçu deux avis défavorables qui est pour
merci contre
merci mes chers collègues absents
abstentions
je vous remercie vous écouter
l'amendement n'est pas adopté le
l'amendement numéro 2 n'est pas défendu
ils tombent l'amendement numéro 1
également je vais donc mettre aux voix
l'article 13 qui est pour voter
l'article 13
je vous remercie qui est contre
merci abstentions l'article 13 et adapté
à la petite tête dehors j'ai une demande
de paroles de jacques berthou vous avez
la parole cher collègue
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission mon propos porte sur
l'article 14 mai pourrait porter
également concerner également les
articles 15 et 16 bis article compris
dans le chapitre iii qui tête de la
protection des infrastructures vitales
contre la cyber menaces il est évident
que l'importance de la cybersécurité de
la cyber défense de la protection de
tous nos réseaux interconnectés n'est
plus à démontrer de nos jours les
potentiels de croissance et de
développement de chaque pays sont
indissociablement liée à l'amélioration
de nos technologies d'information et de
communication
mais c'était cette utilisation est
vulnérable piratage sabotage espionnage
saturation volontaire des réseaux mettre
en danger les centres vitaux de notre
pays c'est la raison pour laquelle
différents systèmes d'information et de
communication doivent être protégés
l'état doit avoir un rôle majeur dans la
définition des politiques de protection
et de défense de l'ensemble de nos
systèmes cette menace est voué à se
renforcer à l'avenir chacun d'entre nous
nos sociétés nos états sont tous les
jours plus dépendant des systèmes
d'information et d'internet alors même
que la diversité de des attaques de
leurs délocalisations ne cesse de se
développer
s'agit également donc de trouver le
cadre législatif le plus adapté pour
limiter les risques de cyber menaces
tout en organisant sous l'autorité du
premier ministre
la coordination de l'action
gouvernementale en matière de défense là
aussi notre sécurité nationale et notre
souveraineté pourrait être mise en cause
par des attaques de ce type je me
réjouis que ces considérations soit 3/10
traduite dans le livre blanc de la
défense ainsi que dans ce projet de loi
de programmation militaire
oui la cyberdéfense est une priorité
nationale et je crois que le
gouvernement
avec ce texte agi avec volonté sur ce
terrain pour démontrer cette volonté
j'évoquerai tout d'abord l'augmentation
des moyens qui seront mises à dix à la
disposition de toute la chaîne de
commandement interarmées et ministériels
des groupes d'intervention rapide
l'hégire et du centre d'analysé de lutte
informatique défensive le khalid eux
mêmes en liens suivis avec l'anzhi
proche de toutes les structures qui ont
des activités de cyberdéfense et dont
les effectifs seront augmentées ainsi le
projet de loi de finances 2014 prévoit
un renforcement significatif des
effectifs de l'ansea et d'augmentation
de 20 % de son budget d'ici 2015 ce
texte permet également à l'état
d'imposer des règles aux opérateurs
d'importance vitale concernant leurs
systèmes d'information critiques il
s'agit ans ainsi de permettre à l'état
de prendre des mesures de lutte
informatique défensive en cas de graves
attaques informatiques tout en opérant
une évolution de notre système juridique
en la matière enfin il me semble qu'il
est de plus en plus important et urgent
de rappeler à l'ensemble des acteurs
économiques de notre pays les dangers
porté par les cyber attaques la prise de
conscience collective et lance l
importance des moyens mis en oeuvre pour
sécuriser au mieux nos atouts
économiques et industriels sont
indispensables à nos intérêts
fondamentaux grâce à 10 c dispositif
ambitieux dont l'article 14 ans rappelle
quelques uns j'ai la conviction monsieur
le ministre que notre pays sera répondre
dans les prochaines années aux défis de
la cyberdéfense je vous remercie chers
collègues j'ai un moment numéro 3 qui
n'est pas défendu ils tombent donc je
vais mettre aux voix l'article 14 qui
est pour voter l'article 14
un vote sur arctique mes chers collègues
je vous remercie qui est contre
abstention
merci l'article 14 est adoptée sur
l'article 15 je ne suis saisi d'aucun
amendement ni d'aucune demande de parole
je mets aux voix cet article qui est
pour
un vote sur l'article merci qui est
contre
abstention l'article est adoptée sur les
articles 16 bis à 34 restant en
discussion je ne suis également saisi
d'aucun amendement d'aucune prise de
parole demande de parole puis je
considérais que le vote est le même et
que ces articles sont adoptées ou selon
le cas la suppression de la tenue c'est
bien adopter donc ces articles sont
adoptés
mes chers collègues des autres
dispositions du projet de loi ne font
pas l'objet de la deuxième lecture je
vais mettre aux voix donc l'ensemble du
projet de loi j'ai été saisi d'une
demande de scrutin public
jeu peut-être qu'il ya des demandes
d'explications de vote sur l'ensemble
oui monsieur de lège voilà
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre est très rapidement une
explication de vote je crois monsieur le
ministre totalement à votre sincérité
dans l'élaboration de ce texte nous
l'avait montré et dans un contexte
difficile pour autant
bien que
vous soyez totalement sincère le texte
porte quelques incertitudes et et
imperfections je voudrais en pointe et
très rapidement quelques unes
d'abord
ça démarre mal la programmation puisque
il ya un report de trois milliards 6
vous nous avez dit moins 500 millions
mais en tous les cas il s'agit là d'une
promesse et donc nous nous démarrons une
programmation militaire avec dès le
départ un déficit deuxièmement sur les
recettes on a déjà eu l'occasion de
s'expliquer je crois que vous les ferez
je pense simplement vous ne le ferez pas
dans le calendrier que vous vous êtes
fixé et c'est une deuxième source
d'incertitude troisièmement essais liés
à l'observation que je viens de faire à
partir de 2016
vous avez prévu un renforcement je
dirais des crédits traditionnels de
l'état puisque les recettes
exceptionnelles auront été faites il me
semble que la
drac quelques difficultés sans doute à
être au rendez vous ferait qu'à
croissance reparte et donc tous auront
sans doute un chevauchement entre
des recettes traditionnelles qui
viendront pas et et des recettes
exceptionnelles qui n'auront pas encore
été totalement réalisée
quatrième point et l'actualité nous le
montre c'est sans doute un
sous-financement des opex le 5e - c'est
la clause de sauvegarde
ici à meilleure fortune nous dit on
espérons le si les opex coûte plus cher
que prévu on prélèvera sur les autres
budgets avoué chers collègues à ce stade
c'est une déclaration d'intention même
et rien d'autre et cette déclaration
d'intention n'a aucune valeur juridique
aucune valeur d'engagement
autre point de fragilité d'incertitude
c'est vous nous l'avez dit
l'externalisation d'un certain nombre de
fonctions on n'a pas prouvé par le passé
que c'était forcément une source
d'économie et surtout ce qui nous
inquiète c'est que cette externalisation
aurait pour effet de porter
principalement sur les fonctions de
soutien est en période d'intervention je
me suis pas certain que
l'autonomie de nos armées s'en trouvera
renforcée
enfin et c'est le dernier point
président de la république s'était
engagé un redressement des finances
publiques dans la justice il me semble
qu entre les différents départements
ministériels
c'était fort de justice et donc d'
équilibre et pas très bien répartie
puisque ce sont quand même les forces
armées qui porte principalement la
diminution des effectifs alors monsieur
le ministre wakan aux arv et nous devons
la sincérité je crois que votre discours
est sincère mais je crains hélas qu'il
soit assez en décalage avec les actes
que vous nous demandez de voter à la
faveur de cette loi de programmation
militaire c'est la raison pour laquelle
bon nombre de membres du groupe ump
votre rencontre c'est toi de
programmation je vous remercie je vous
remercie chers collègues d'une voix plus
ou moins de paroles je vais donc que
vous dire que j'ai été saisi d'une
demande du scrutin public par la
commission des affaires étrangères de la
défense et des forces armées et du
groupe ump sur l'ensemble du projet de
loi de programmation militaire pour les
années et 2014 à 2019 il va donc être
procédé au scrutin public dans les
conditions fixées par l'article 56 du
règlement le scrutin sera ouvert dans
quelques instants
le scrutin est ouvert
mes chers collègues plus personne ne
demande à voter
le scrutin est donc close avec les
secrétaires a procédé au dépouillement
résultat du scrutin numéro 90 sur
l'ensemble du projet de loi nombre de
votants 347 nombre de suffrages exprimés
310 pour l'adoption 164 contre 146 le
sénat a définitivement adopté le projet
de loi relatif à la programmation
militaire pour les années 2014 et 2019
et portant diverses dispositions
concernant la défense et la sécurité
nationale
voilà pour ce projet de loi sur la
programmation militaire pour la période
2014 à 2019 vous l'avez vu le sénat donc
adopté ce texte et il a adopté dans les
mêmes termes que l'assemblée nationale
ce qui signifie que le parlement adopte
définitivement
adopté ce projet de loi vous pouvez bien
sûr toujours voir et revoir toutes les
séances sur notre site publicsenat.fr
prochain rendez vous de l'actualité
parlementaire cet après midi à 16h30
pour une table ronde portant sur le
financement des universités
très bonne journée sur les chaînes
parlementaires